hey there welcome to selenium webdriver
tutorial by simply learn my name is
anaga and today in this video we'll be
talking about the selenium webdriver
basics what is that you should be
expecting from this video let's see what
a selenium whenever we are learning
about any tool it's good to know a
little bit brief history of it so we
will look into how selenium has evolved
over years to become the most popular
web application automation tool and why
use webdriver and then we will
understand what a selenium driver while
we learn this i will also be touching
upon some drawbacks of manual testing
and how automation helps and then a deep
dive into architecture of webdriver as
you know every automation tool has its
own advantages and limitations so we
will be understanding the limitations of
selenium webdriver and how we work
around this and then i will demonstrate
the webdriver in action for which i will
use a simple web application use case to
automate so let's get started so before
we talk about selenium let's understand
a few drawbacks of manual testing let's
take an example of a very simple use
case as a user i want to login to my web
application using username and password
a very simple use case and it's a very
common use case for any kind of web
application you're working so as a
tester what do i do i need to write
multiple test case to test this use case
so i can use multiple data sets like
valid credentials invalid credentials
null values and so on to test this
particular use case and then what you do
you start executing the test cases one
by one you find bugs then your
developers fixes them and then you will
need to rerun all the test cases again
and again until all the bugs of for this
use case are fixed and your application
is ready to ship now look into this now
this brings us to the first merit
demerit of the manual testing which is
what if one has to run test cases with
hundred transactions and repeat them
again and again this is going to be a
very time consuming process and very
boring also it is more error prone since
it's done manually and human mistakes
are bound to happen the third challenge
is the scope of manual testing itself is
very limited for example say regression
testing ideally you would want to run
all the test cases which you have
written but since it's a manual process
this is going to be very tedious to do
and also you would not have all the
luxury of time to execute all test cases
so what do you do you start picking up
those test cases which are very
important to be run and that way you are
kind of limiting the scope of your
testing also working with large amount
of data manually is going to be
impractical what about performance
testing you want to collect metrics on
various performance measure as a part of
your performance testing you want to
simulate multiple loads on your
application under test and all these
things manually it is very difficult to
perform and it's not feasible also and
to submit all this creating manual test
reports after running all the tests who
wants to really do that and again
another level of challenge here is say
if you're working on an agile model
where code is being churned out by
developers the testers are building
their test cases executing them as and
when the bills are available to them
this happens iteratively and hence you
will need to run all those test cases
which you have written multiple times
during your development cycle and doing
this manually definitely is going to be
very tedious and boring and is this
effective of doing it no so what do we
do we automate it so this tells us why
we want to automate one for faster
execution two to be less error prone
three to help frequent execution of our
tests so there were many tools available
in the market for automation one such
tool was selenium and that brings us to
the slide advent of selenium so much
before selenium there are various tools
in the market like rft qtp just to name
a few popular ones so selenium was
introduced by a gentleman called jason
huggins way back in 2004. he was an
engineer at thoughtworks he was kind of
working on a web application which
needed frequent testing and he realized
the inefficiency in doing manual testing
of his application repeatedly so what he
did was he wrote a javascript program
that automatically controlled the
browser actions and then he named that
as javascript test runner he made this
open source which was later renamed as
selenium core and this is how the
selenium came into existence so with
this brief history of selenium let's
understand what is selenium and what are
its main features selenium is the most
popular and widely used automation tool
for automating web applications it
enables us to test web application on
different kind of process like internet
explorer chrome firefox safari opera and
so on and also they introduced support
for edge browser after microsoft
introduced it selenium is a set of tools
and libraries to facilitate automation
of web application it is not a single
tool it has multiple components and
those we will be seeing uh in some time
all these tools together help us test
the web application so selenium is open
source and it is platform independent
this is the biggest reason why people
are preferring this tool because it is
free of cost qtp and rft which i just
talked about are a chargeable one
selenium scripts can run on any platform
because selenium is primarily developed
in javascript so it is platform
independent well as you know it's common
for manual testers not to have in-depth
programming background so selenium has a
record and replay back tool called the
selenium ide which can be used to create
a set of actions as a script and to
replay that script but this is mainly
used for demo purpose why because
selenium is such a powerful tool that
you should be able to take advantage of
all its feature and not just be with a
record and replay tool right so that way
there are a lot of record and replay
tool anyway available in the market the
selenium provides support for different
programming language java python c-sharp
ruby php and so on you can write your
test scripts in any language you prefer
or you like and again as i said one need
not really know in-depth or advanced
knowledge of these languages you would
still be able to write the selenium
scripts with the basic knowledge of this
programming language and also selenium
supports various operating systems you
can run selenium test on windows mac or
linux or even say if you have ubuntu
machine you can always run your selenium
test on ubuntu machines so of you can
run the test on any platform of your
choice okay so let's go now a little
more deeper into selenium so i said that
selenium is not a single tool but it is
a suite of tools right so now let's look
at what are those major components which
comprises of the selenium suite first
one is the selenium ide so selenium ide
is the most simplest tool in the whole
suite of the selenium it is nothing but
it's an integrated development
environment earlier this ide was simply
a firefox extension and it offered a
record and playback functionality it was
a very simple and easy to use and as i
said mainly this is used for prototyping
or for only the demo purposes right and
not creating automation for your
real-time projects because you know of
its own limitation of being a simple
recorded replay too however selenium
what happened selenium ide it died with
firefox 55. so that means uh the support
for ide was stopped from firefox 55
version but the good news is very
recently all new brand new selenium ide
has been launched and also what they
have done is they've made this cross
browser that means you can install the
extension on chrome the id extension on
chrome or as an add-on on firefox so it
is supported on both the browsers
firefox and chrome all right so while we
are talking of this ide let me also show
you
how the latest id on the chrome looks
okay for that let me go and launch my
chrome browser so let me just open a new
tab and what i'll do is i'll search for
selenium id for chrome download then i
go to this website and then you can see
a selenium id offered by seleniumhq.org
so what i simply need to do is like you
install any extension on your chrome
browsers i just say add to chrome and
this adds this extension on your chrome
browser now it is added so selenium ide
has been added to chrome use this
extension by clicking the side screen so
can you see this icon here which is
selenium id that's it so once you have
installed this you are free to start
using the id on this chrome browser
similarly you can do adding of this
add-on which is called as add-on on
firefox so go to the firefox browser
search for the selenium id and just
install that add-on so let's get back to
our presentation so that's about the id
so what's our next component our next
component is selenium rc which is
nothing but selenium remote control
selenium rc is used to write web
application test in different
programming languages it interacts with
the browser with the help of rc server
it has an rc server through which only
it can interact with the web browsers
and how does it communicate it uses a
simple http get and post request and
this is what was called as selenium 1.0
version but it got deprecated in 2.0
version and it was completely removed in
3.0 and was replaced with something
called as web driver so we will be
talking in detail about why this
happened what were the drawbacks of rc
which led to replacing with the web
driver so now that brings us to third
component which is the selenium
webdriver this is the most important
component it is just a programming
interface to create and execute our test
cases of course it's a successor of rc
because there were certain drawbacks
which i just mentioned and we will be
going in detail of what it were so
driver what the major difference what we
see with the web driver is the
architecture of the web driver is much
simpler than rc for the reason that
webdriver interacts with the browser
directly unlike your rc where it needs
an rc server to interact with the
browser so this gave a lot of advantage
an edge over the rc the fourth component
selenium grid selenium grid is used to
run multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time with selenium
driver you can only do the sequential
execution however in real time
environment you know that there is
always a need to run tests on
distributed environment for example say
you have a web application and say you
have automated around hundreds of
thousands of test cases and you need to
run them as a regression suite and also
one of the ask is that you need to run
this on multiple browsers and multiple
os why since you have automated them and
your application supports multiple
browsers and os now imagine the time
taken to run these thousand test cases
sequentially with the web driver right
it's going to take quite a bit of time
so what you need is to run this parallel
on multiple machines matrix across the
browsers and operating system and that
is where the grid helps you in achieving
that so grid has this hub and node
concept and it helps in achieving the
parallel execution which i just talked
about so you can check out our detailed
video on selenium grid on simply learn
all right so now we talked about the
components of the selenium so let's look
at the different versions it evolved
into so when i talked about rc i
mentioned that this was selenium one
version so now let's understand how this
evolved over years and what it offers
today so when jason huggins introduced
selenium the tool was called javascript
program he called it as javascript test
runner it had one major issue now that
is something called a same origin policy
so what is the same origin policy it
says that a javascript when executed in
a domain can access web pages in that
domain only and it cannot access any web
pages in another domain i will repeat it
same origin policies dictates that a
javascript is executed in a domain can
access web pages in that domain only and
it cannot access web pages in another
domain for example say every web page
inside google.com domain like search
email drive can be accessible but
nothing outside of google.com like say
if you want to access a web page and say
amazon or yahoo is possible to access
why because of the simple reason which
is the security reasons now to overcome
this paul homan created something called
a selenium remote control server and why
did he create that he wanted to trick
the browser in believing that the
selenium core through which you're going
to run your scripts and your web
application under test are in the same
domain with which you are able to
achieve run your test on your web
application without having to get into
this issue of same origin policy so this
is what was a version one of selenium
and we called it as selenium remote
control and then what happened in 2007
simon stewart okay he invented this web
driver now why did he invent this
because the architecture of selenium rc
was little complicated rc required a
separate server to talk to your browsers
so what he did was he removed the
requirement of having a separate server
in the rc and this was the selenium 2
version now since it was a transition
phase both the selenium rc and the web
driver co-existed in selenium 2. while
the web driver was still under
development and then what happened in
3.0 selenium is the selenium core which
is the rc was completely deprecated and
only the web driver was made available
so in this series of videos we will be
working with selenium 3.0 and now
selenium 4 is already around the corner
so alpha is already released as of the
day when this video was made and i
believe some of the features what the
selenium 4 is going to offer is they are
moving towards w3c webdriver
standardization one and also there there
is going to be an improved id the id
which i just talked about that it's a
improved version of the previous id and
then an improved version of selenium
grid also so they might be doing a gui
based grid right so these are some of
the major features expected in this
version why selenium webdriver so let's
look at what led to replacement of
selenium rc with this webdriver for that
first we need to understand the selenium
rc and its shortcoming as i said
selenium rc is a simple tool to write
tests for web applications in various
supported programming languages like
java python ruby and c and this is the
architecture of the selenium rc at a
very high level first you need to write
test scripts in any of the supported
languages of your choice so if you're
more familiar with java you would be
writing your test scripts all your
commands in the java so before we start
writing the test one of the major
requirement right required for the rc to
run is your rc server so first you need
to start this rc server before you run
even a single line of code and this rc
server is a separate application and now
what is the function of this rc server
the selenium server or the rc server is
responsible for receiving cellini's
commands from your test script it
interprets them and then reports the
result back to your selenium tester now
what are the selenius commands these
commands are nothing but the commands
returned in your test script these are
called as selenius command that is what
the selenium server does now after the
selenium servers function let's look at
how the browser interaction happens the
browser interaction happens through this
rc server this rc server uses a simple
http post and get request to communicate
and how does this communication happen
this rc server acts like a proxy say for
example your test scripts asks for
launching a browser this command from
your test script goes to the server and
then this rc server launches the browser
injects its javascript into the browser
once this is done all the subsequent
calls that is all the subsequent calls
is all the rest of the commands which
you have written after launching the
browser go to this rc server and then to
the actual web server so it routes all
the commands are getting routed through
your rc server to your web browser upon
receiving this instruction so what does
the code do it executes these commands
as the javascript commands on your
browser so once these are executed the
response from the browser or the results
what you say are sent back to the rc
server and rc server is responsible for
sending it back to your test and then
the test results are displayed here now
if you see this complete cycle from
starting your command from your test
script talking to the rc server then rc
server talks to the web browser it
injects the javascript here runs your
command takes back the results sends it
to rc server and then back to this test
script this whole cycle gets repeated
for every command which is written in
your test script and this is how your
test case gets executed all right so now
everything is fine so great we are
unable to run the scripts we are able to
launch the browser we are able to
execute all the commands so what was the
problem here why was still rc not good
enough for the reason why the rc was
still not good enough was one the
architecture of rc is very complicated
because of that intermediate rc server
to communicate with the browser so there
is no direct interaction with the
browser this rc server needs to be
installed before running any test
scripts that means it has an additional
setup because that is rc server is a
mediator between your selenium commands
and your browser the execution of the
commands takes very long time it is very
slow why because we saw that every
command written in your test scripts
needs to make a full trip from your test
script to the rc server to the core to
the browser and then back which makes
your overall automation test execution
very very slow so how does selenium
webdriver now overcomes this this is a
simple architecture of selenium
webdriver even in web driver we have
test scripts we have a web browser and a
web server however we do not have an
additional server for communication like
the rc server which we saw in the
selenium rc this makes the architecture
of web driver very simple the selenium
web driver that's one of the biggest
advantages the selenium web driver does
not use an additional server then
secondly it makes direct calls to your
browser using your browser's native
support automation so since there is no
intermediate server there the browser is
controlled directly from the operating
system level itself now due to this
direct communication the overall the
trips what we saw from the rc server to
the browser and from the browser back to
the rc server and to the test scripts
right this was an indirect communication
since this whole thing was avoided the
speed of test execution is much faster
in rc and this overall architecture of
the web driver if you see it is much
much simpler than what the rc provides
so this was the major drawback from the
rc and this is where webdriver replaced
rc now was that all because of the
architecture no there were few other
shortcomings with the rc api is in
selenium rc a single function has
several commands redundant and confusing
apis rca is less object oriented api
though there are good set of apis to
work with they are pretty redundant and
confusing for example how and when to
use a type key or a type command another
example is the mouse commands click or
to use click at or when to use mouse at
or mouse stop so this was getting pretty
confusing for the developers and to top
it all this every browser interprets the
command differently which makes your
test cases brittle when it has to work
on the multiple process developers had a
tough time making their scripts cross
browser and they had to add browser
specific code whereas selenium driver
comes with a set of more matured and
simpler api which are pretty
straightforward to use for example a
simple click to simulate a click action
on any web element send keys which
simply means send the text to any web
element on your web page scroll up or
down on the web page and so on so we
will see more of this commands when we
actually start working with the web
driver another difference is the browser
support though both rc and webdriver
supports multiple browser rc does not
have support for html unit which is a
headless browser whereas the web driver
supports testing on headless browser now
what is the seedless browser headless
browser is a browser which does not have
a ui it makes testing much faster
because it does not need a real browser
for testing now to summarize all this so
if you look at the rc and the webdriver
comparison which we talked about rc is a
complex architecture whereas webdriver
has a simple architecture for the main
reason that webdriver removed the need
of having an intermediate server rc the
execution of your test cases or your
automation scripts is much slower than
the web driver rca requires a rc server
to interact with the browser whereas the
selenium web driver interacts with the
browser directly using the web drivers
also we saw the apis which rc provides
which are pretty confusing and web
drivers we have much easier and easy to
use apis no support for html unit
browser which is a headlight browser
selenium driver also provides support
for html unit browser now that we have
understood what selenium rc is and why
webdriver replaced rc let's go another
level deeper into webdriver so what is
selenium webdriver we know that the web
driver in its simplest term is a tool or
a programming interface to create and
execute test cases on a web application
it supports multiple browsers ie firefox
chrome opera safari edge and it also has
support for headless browser so we will
know in some time what is in headless
browser some of the features of
webdriver so while rc was introduced in
2004 web driver got introduced by simon
stewart in 2006. webdriver can run on
any platform of your choice linux
windows mac and even if you have a
ubuntu machine you can run your selenium
web drive and what is this actual web
driver is it an ide no it is a simply
and programming interface to run your
test cases and how does it work the test
cases are created and executed using web
elements or the objects using web
locators and webdriver methods so once
we get into the demo or once you start
understanding how selenium works you
will understand what are these webdriver
methods and the locating techniques
which are used to perform these actions
on web element selenium web driver is
pretty fast why since the web driver
interacts directly with the browser and
does not have an intermediate server
like rc each browser with which you want
to work with has its own driver on which
your application runs and this driver is
responsible to make the browser
understand the command which are being
passed from your script like a click of
button or entering some text in any of
the input fields through your scripts
you tell which browser you want to work
with say you want to do all this action
say on the chrome browser if you want to
work with chrome browser then the chrome
driver is responsible for interpreting
your instructions from your test case
and executing them on the web
application which is launched on chrome
browser earlier so like rc webdriver
also supports multi-programming
languages in which you can write your
test scripts like the ones which are
listed here also webdriver supports
different frameworks like test ng junit
and n unit when we talk about the
limitations of webdriver you will
appreciate how this support for various
frameworks and tools help in making the
selenium a complete automation solution
for web application now let's try to
know what is the architecture of
selenium webdriver webdriver has four
different components in it one we have
the client libraries or what is also
called as language binding since i said
selenium supports multiple languages and
you're free to use any of the supported
languages to create your automation
script there are libraries available on
selenium website which you need to
download and use them let me show you
that so let's go to my chrome browser so
i have the selenium hq website already
launched here so guys if you're working
on selenium this website selenium hq dot
org is going to be bible so everything
and whatever you need to know and work
with selenium is available here for now
we want to see the client library so the
language binding so for that what you
need to do is if you go to the download
section here can you see the selenium
client and web driver language binding
so for each of the languages which is
supported you have a client library
which you can download from here so if
you're working on java you need to
download the java libraries if you're
working on python you need to download
the python libraries right so these are
called as language bindings so selenium
provides lot of apis for us to interact
with the browser and when we do the demo
i will be showing some of those apis now
what are these abs these apis are the
rest apis rest is representational
stateful aps and everything for selenium
happens to this rest calls the second
component is the json wire protocol so
what is json javascript object notation
and it's a standard for exchanging data
over the web so for example you want to
launch a web application through your
script so what selenium does is it
creates a json payload and post the
request to the browser driver right and
where are these browser drivers these
are here right and what are these
browser drivers these are a driver
specific to each browser so if you see
here you can see drivers for chrome
firefox opera safari and edgerate so we
interact with the actual browsers here
using these drivers and how does this
happen this driver establishes
connection with the real browser without
revealing the internal logic of browser
functionality right that's exactly the
function of this browser driver now what
does that mean let's say we want to
execute a test script so what happens
when the script is executed is an http
request is generated and sent to browser
driver for each command in the script
and then the driver receives the request
through this http server and does all
the execution on the actual browser once
the execution is done the execution
results are just sent back over the same
http server to your test scripts so this
is the simplest form of the architecture
of the selenium webdriver well now as
every tool has its own advantages and
its limitations so let's look at what
selenium limited webdriver limitations
are cannot test mobile applications
requires framework like apm selenium is
for automating web application it cannot
handle mobile right mobile applications
are different and they have its own set
of automation tools however what
selenium provides is the support for
integrating this apm tool apm tool is
one of the popular tools for mobile
application automation right so it
provides a support for integrating apm
tools so using apm and selenium you can
still achieve mobile application
automation now when do you usually use
this in cases where say your application
under test is also supported on mobile
devices so that means you need a
mechanism to run your test cases on your
web browser as well as your mobile
browsers right and this is how you
achieve it using selenium when we talked
about components of selenium i said that
a web driver can achieve only sequential
execution but in real time we know that
we just cannot live with this we need to
have a parallel execution on multiple
machines and on multiple process so this
limitation of webdriver is replaced by
having the grid which helps us in
achieve the parallel execution and do
check out our video on more details on
selenium grid selenium webdriver has
limited reporting capability it can help
create basic reports but definitely we
need more especially when we are working
on a big project we need good reports to
be created so what it does is we have a
support for multiple tools like test ng
report ng and even the extent reports
which you can integrate with selenium
and generate beautiful reports isn't it
really powerful all right there's
another challenge what we have these are
amongst few of the challenges what i
have put across here there are other
challenges also but always there is a
workaround to get through this challenge
so another challenge which we have
mentioned here is selenium is not very
good with image testing especially
designed for web application automation
but then we have other tools which can
be used along with selenium to achieve
any kind of image testing you want to do
like auto it and securely so same way
the way it provides a mechanism to
integrate apm so selenium also provides
a way for integrating autoit and the
secular tools so if you look at all this
selenium still provides a complete
solution for our automation need and
that's the beauty of selenium that makes
it most powerful tool today for
automation okay so let's look at
webdriver in action so before we do that
let's understand some of the basic
browser commands and functions that we
will be using in our demo today the get
commands so there are six get commands
to perform various actions on the
browser driver.get this is used to
launch any website application it takes
a string argument and this needs to be a
fully formed url which you want to
launch driver.gettitle so this method
fetches the title of the web page which
you're working with so for example let's
go to ebay so if you just hover your
mouse here can you see the text there
electronics cars fashion collectibles
coupons and more ebay so this is nothing
but title of this current page and this
command helps us to get the title get
current url so to get the url of any
page is when you want to use this
command so this will be used especially
when you're working with multiple web
pages and you want to say print whatever
the current url you're working on on the
console get page source this method
dumps the complete html page source on
your console actually this is not really
much used uh unless you really need to
look at anything in your html pages and
then there are two more get commands
related to windows handles these are
used for handling multiple tabs and
multiple windows on the browser now we
will not be dealing with this in today's
demo however if you want to know the
details of this command these are
available in our video tutorials for
this commands the next set of commands
are the navigational commands so these
are self explanatory and basically are
used to navigate between the multiple
pages of your web application the first
one the driver.navigate.2
is very similar to driver.get so both
does the same function and then you have
navigate dot back navigate got forward
and navigate dot refresh so this is used
for refreshing your browser page and
then there are two commands browser
commands which we use one is the
driver.close so this closes the current
browser window so if you have got
multiple tabs opened in the window and
you want to close a particular tab so
that is when you use driver.close and
driver.quit what it does it quits the
entire browser session then there are
few other commands and
these some of the commands are listed
here however if you see there's a huge
list of commands available in selenium
and since we'll be using just a few of
them in today's demo i have listed here
so let's just understand these very
basic commands which we will be using
driver dot find element now when you
want to work with any application what
is that you need to do you need to
perform actions on the elements of the
web page and these are called as web
elements for example let's go to our
ebay dot in so on this website say you
want to search for jbl speakers and what
do you do when you want to search for
this you would identify the search box
and you will enter the text jbl speakers
right and then you go ahead and click on
the search button so this is the set of
operations which you will do now for us
to write this and this is exactly what
you need to do through your commands for
us to really write this text as jbl
speakers i need to know what this
particular element is okay so this
particular input box is my web element
which i need to identify similarly if i
want to click on the search button i
need to identify what this button is and
that's exactly is done by using
driver.find element selenium has
multiple ways of finding these elements
it has eight element locating techniques
and our future videos on selenium do
cover these eight element locating
techniques very much in detail so for us
right now we will be using couple of
them so one is with id and one is with
the link text the next one the send keys
so as the name indicates it is used to
send a certain text to any web element
you have identified or you want to work
with like in this example as i said
since we want to search for jbl speakers
right i would be basically sending the
text jbl speakers to this web element
using send keys click so after entering
the text what we need to do i said we
need to click on the search button so
for all such actions we have methods
defined in selling and one of them is
this click what this does is it just
clicks on the web element or the button
which we want to work with so now with
these basic commands let's go ahead and
start writing our code for our test case
so what is the test case we are going to
write today so this is my use case today
so use case one as a user i want to log
into ebay application search for jbl
speakers and then i want to check the
today's team so there is something
called as the days deal we will go and
click on that and see what are the deals
available i have another use case here
what says is from this website from
wherever we are right navigate to the
simply learn website and navigate back
to the ebay. so this using this use case
2 what i want to show you is how do we
use the navigational commands and my
third use case is from the ebay.in i
want to print the page title and close
the browser so with this we are trying
to demonstrate at least few commands
from each of the categories which we
talked about so i will be using eclipse
for writing our test scripts and if you
want to know how to get started with
selenium how do we install selenium you
can refer to our videos on installation
of selling name by simply done okay let
me go to my eclipse so in eclipse what i
have done is i have already created a
project called selenium demo and in this
project i have gone ahead and created a
java class in which we will be writing
our test case so the java class which i
have created is ebay search dot java and
also what i have done is if you look at
few import statements here i have
imported all the required selenium jars
here so if you look here in the
referenced libraries the way after we
you work with java here right so java is
the prereq for your eclipse so you
already have the java libraries
available here so what i need to do is i
also need to import the selenium jar
face and this is the list of seldium jar
files which you will need to work with
the selling and this i've already
imported for you then another thing what
i do as a following a best practice is
instead of writing all my code under
this main function here what i do is i
create methods for each of the use case
or the test case which i am writing so
same thing i am going to do that today
for all the use cases which we have
taken for this demo now let us get
started so what is the first thing which
we need to do the first thing what we
need to do is you need to declare your
web driver so which i've already done
here i've said web driver driver and
then i need to launch the browser before
even i go into ebay dot in and start
performing the other testing now for me
to launch browser this is one method
which i have already written here so let
me walk you through this so there are
multiple steps we need to follow for
launching the browser the first thing is
set system property so let's understand
this particular command here the one
which i have highlighted so this is used
to set the property for your gecko
driver now what is a gecko driver if you
remember while we are talking of web
driver architecture i said for whichever
browser you want to work with you need
to tell the web driver as which browser
is what you're going to test with and in
my case here i'm going to be using
firefox browser and also if you remember
while explaining the architecture i said
every browser every browser has its own
driver which you need to download and
install and where is this driver let's
go ahead and see that on the
seleniumhq.org
so let me go to my chrome browser i
already have a selenium hq dot org
website open here now on this website in
the download section if you go down you
can see something called as third party
drivers binding and plugins and here you
would see a list of all browsers gecko
driver chrome opera edge right and html
unit which is headless browser so all
these browsers with selenium supports
listed and for each of this browser we
have a driver associated with it which
we can download so if i want a gig or
driver what i need to do is i need to
click on this latest link this will take
me to the latest web driver which is
available so depending on the operating
system which you're using right now i'm
using a mac so i've already downloaded
it so once you download you need to
place it in a particular directory okay
so let us go back to this and now if you
see this path here what i'm highlighting
this is where i have kept my gecko
driver so this gecko driver what you see
is my executable so if you are using
using a windows machine it will be
geckodriver.exe so this is the driver
which should be working with now coming
back to the system.set property this
particular method or this particular
command is used to set your driver
property it is a key value pair and you
will need to know which keys depending
on the which browsers you are working
with since i am working on the firefox
browser the key which i need to set is
the webdriver gecko.driver if i'm using
chrome what i simply do is i have a key
called chrome and then i would set this
path to chrome driver and this is
exactly you need to do so for you to
even before launch the browser you need
to do this set property so let me change
this back to gecko so now we are clear
till here now what is the next command
which we need to after setting the
property is after setting the property
you have to instantiate the webdriver
which is done by using this particular
command driver is equal to new firefox
driver so once you do this your browser
is going to get launched then once your
browser is launched what is the next
step you do you would be launching the
application on which you want to perform
your test and that is done by using the
command which we just saw now driver.kit
now since i'm going to be working with
ebay.in i have just said driver.get and
the url fully formed url so this
particular method is going to help me
launch the firefox browser and also
launch the ebay application now
advantage of using methods like this is
you can reuse this methods in every test
case which you are going to write or you
can make a common function of this and
just call this function in any of your
test cases now for me to call this
method what am i going to do i am going
to create an object of this class let's
do that object is equal to newton and
then i need to call this method obj dot
launch browser good so far all right so
now let's get to the first use case so
let's go back to our presentation and
see what was our first use case our
first use case was that we want to
launch the ebay application which we
have already done in the launch browser
method and then we want to search for
jbl speakers now for that what we will
do let me create a method here so i will
call this method i'll say public void
say
search product that's my method name so
i have created a method called search
product now what i need to do is i need
to search for jbl speaker so for that
let me go to my firefox browser and i
need to first identify the search box
element so for identifying what i do i
go to this website i go to this element
and then i say inspect element so now i
know that there is already an id which
is unique to this particular web element
available so i'm going to make use of
this id i need to go to my eclipse so
now here i'm going to use the find
element method so for that i'll say
driver dot find element i'll say by dot
id and it's a string argument i'll just
copy the id which i copied from the
firefox browser and then what is the
operation i need to do here i need to
send keys and what is the keys i need to
send the product which i am searching
for i am searching for say jbl speakers
done so with this command what it will
do is it will enter the text jbl
speakers in the search box after doing
this i need to click on the search
button now similarly i need to identify
what is the web element search for this
again i already have a unique id here
which i'm just going to simply copy from
here and use it in the find elements so
same thing i will do driver dot find
element by dot id and this is the id of
the button and here what is my operation
i need to click done good so far now
other thing what we also need to
understand here is so what happens
sometimes depending on the website some
websites are pretty slow even by loading
the page and some are pretty fast now
for the selenium to work without having
to fail or without having to create
exception of not finding the elements it
is good to use certain weights so while
we need to use weights say for example
when after entering the jbl speakers and
after clicking the button it's going to
take a while for it to search for jbl
speakers and give us that webpage with
the list of jpm speakers and even before
we start doing the first command like
searching once we load the page it takes
time for the complete page to get loaded
okay so selenium provides lot of
synchronization commands right and it's
a very big topic on its own which needs
to be used especially when you're
working with any kind of website okay so
there is a since it's a separate topic
there's a separate video which will help
you understand how to use the
synchronization now for the demo purpose
we have certain weight commands which
can be used and that is exactly which
i'm going to use here so that is called
as thread dot sleep so what this does is
say i'm going to give 2000 here what
this does is this basically this script
waits for two seconds right after the
previous command is executed and then it
executes your next command which is our
find element now this is showing us an
exception because it wants us to add a
exception here at throws declaration
which is interrupted exception okay we
need to do this so once we are done okay
we have done the click so let's see what
is the first use case which we had have
we covered everything in the first use
case okay we said log in to ebay done
search for jbl speakers and then i want
to check on the day's d okay we need to
do this also so for that again what we
need to do is we need to go and identify
so what i will do i'll use the inspector
here and look for this daily deals now
this is a link text it's an anchor tag
so what i will do i'll copy this link
text daily deals i'll go to my eclipse
now after this i will give another
thread dot sleep of say two seconds that
should be more than enough and then i'll
say driver dot find element now this
time i will be using something called as
link text and here as an argument as a
parameter i am going to paste the daily
deals which i just copied and then what
do i need to do on this web element i
just need to do a click operation done
so the complete first use case we have
covered so what we will do is let's go
ahead and execute this first use case
now i have launched the browser here i
also need to call this method which is
search product now again here since we
are
doing that add through declaration on
the method we also need to do it for the
main function exception added i'll save
this and for me to run this what i do is
i simply right click on that and i say
run as java application now we see that
our firefox browser is launched the ebay
application is also launched and jbl
speakers entered and search clicked so
we have a list of jbl speakers here and
now as per our test case it has to go on
the daily days which it just did great
all right so we have our first use case
working so right now i have not used the
browser.close so what i will do is i'll
just manually go and close this process
so we are done with our first use case
now let's move to our second use case so
what second use case says is from
wherever you are right now we are on the
ebay.in navigate to simply learn website
and then navigate back to ebay. so let's
see how to handle that so let's go back
to my eclipse here now let's create
another method instead of saying test
case 2 or use case 2 will give a more
meaningful name i'll say navigate since
we are exercising the navigates command
navigate commands here i'll just use
this method now so we have done the
click so i need a quick thread dot sleep
here because i want it to wait so that
we can see otherwise it's going to be so
fast we will not be able to see what are
the operations in it so i'll just add a
thread dot sleep before we start
navigating to the new website okay
thread dot sleep and i guess two seconds
should be good enough even here so same
thing we need to add the exception so
add throws declaration and interrupted
exception all right done so now what we
need to do is we need to navigate to the
simplylearn.com so for that first i need
a fully formed url of the website which
i want to launch okay so let me go to
and here instead of ebay dot in i would
say let's search for simply learn i have
it here and i just pick this from here
https
www.simplylearn.com so let me go to my
eclipse and here we saw another command
like get we said navigate dot 2 so let's
use the same command so i'll say driver
dot navigate dot 2 and i'm going to use
two url because or you can just use a
string because this is going to be a
string variable now what does this
command do this will simply navigate to
the url which we have specified here now
here again i'm going to give a quick
sleep here so that we are able to see
the website before we navigate back to
the ebay. so i'll use a thread dot sleep
this time probably i'll give a three
second wait then what does our use case
say let's go back to use case once and
check and it says and navigate back to
ebay. so that means i need to use a
driver dot navigate dot can you see the
list of commands here which provide for
which the navigate class provides okay
and the back is what we need to use so
that it comes back to the ebay dot done
so far so good now let's do one thing
before even we go to the use case three
let's execute our test case still here
so what i'll do i'll save this program
and after search product i will call
navigate method okay i will save this
and then right click run as java
application so our firefox is getting
launched it has launched the ebay
application is on so it's going to first
find the jbl speakers click on the
search we have a list of jbl speakers
then it will click on the daily deals
yes it is doing that we got the deals of
the day yes it is now navigating to
simplylearn.com now after three seconds
it should take me back to the ebay. okay
cool so this was the last page where we
left before we navigated to simply right
and that is where we have come back
using the back command so now let me
close this again because i have still
not incorporated the driver.close now
let's look at the use case 3. now use
case 3 says once you're back to ebay.in
print the page title and then close the
browser cool very simple so we'll go
back to eclipse probably in the same
method what i can do is once i'm back
here i will say so i have to use driver
dot get title that was a spelling
mistake driver dot get title okay this
is the method which we are going to use
to get the title of the page now we also
said that once we get the page title we
want to print it on the console now how
do you print it on console you just use
a sis out statement so instead of just
writing this what i will do is i'll
directly write a cis out statement
system.out.println
and i'll write a text as the title of
this page is and then we will
concatenate with
get driver.get as simple as that and
after i do this i will simply call it's
actually i want to call the driver.list
but it's always good to create a
separate method so i'll say public void
close browser method and here i'll
simply say driver dot quit you can use
close or you can use quit so let me
demonstrate how do we use twitter now i
need to call the close browser so simply
what i'll do i'll say obj dot close
browser method okay so this completes
our all three use cases so now let's
execute all these three use cases now
and we should be able to see the title
of this page on the console so same
thing what i do is right click run as
java application okay same thing our
ebay is launched now send keys the jbl
speakers click on search button executed
and then it has to click on the daily
deals that it has done moves to simply
learn website now it has to come back to
ebay.n and we should be able to see the
close process which just happened at the
snap of the finger right now for us to
know whether it really happened what we
have done is we have printed the page
title okay now can you see here we have
the complete page title printed here all
right so let's go back so let's look at
what are the key takeaways from that so
in this overall video we saw what was
selenium what is selenium webdriver what
was the limitation of the remote control
which is selenium rc how did webdriver
replaced it and we went into learning
the architecture of the selenium web
travel which is very important for us to
understand because we will be working
with the web driver to create all our
automation scripts and then as i said
every tool has its own limitation we
also talked about limitations at a very
high level and also as there are
workarounds and then i also demo some of
the browser apis and the usages and some
of the methods which we use with
selenium this video focuses on teaching
how to use selenium ide for creating
automation scripts what does this video
cover one a brief about selenium and
where the ide actually fits in very
recently a new version of ide has been
launched so we will look at what it has
to offer how does the record and replay
tool work and then let's understand the
components of this id interface we will
work with few commonly used selenium
commands and then since we are using the
new ide let's look at some of the key
features of the selenium id and like
every tool has its own
limitations we will also look at what
are the limitations of selenium ide so
what is selenium so selenium is an
automated testing tool used to test web
applications across various browsers in
my previous video where we have covered
the complete basics of selenium
webdriver i have explained each and
every components of the selenium suite
so selenium ide is one of the components
in the selenium suite and other
components of the suite are selenium rc
webdriver and selenium grid so in this
video we will be looking in detail about
how the selenium id works so what is
selenium id selenium ide was developed
way back in 2006. it was created to
facilitate a simple record and replay of
the test automation so record and replay
tools were pretty much invoked during
this time and the main advantage of
using such tool was an automation
engineer was not really required to know
any knowledge of programming he could
just use this record replay tool and
create the automation and this ide was
available as a firefox extension so for
one to use it you need to just go ahead
and install the extension on firefox and
then use its recording and record the
steps of your test execution it is a
very simple interface which helps in
building the automation scripts and how
this works you just need to start the
recording on id perform your test steps
on the browser and these steps gets
recorded in the script and then what you
could do is you could export the script
into say a web driver or a junit ruby or
any javascripts and then you can use it
now however the record and replay tool
is not a very powerful automation tool
and hence this ide is mainly used for
prototyping or you could say demo
purpose now since selenium webdriver
itself offers such powerful capability
of creating robust test scripts ide more
or less remains as a prototyping tool
only so in short as i said ide is a part
of overall selenium set of tools and
mainly developed to speed up the
creation of test cases and what is the
other advantage of that one need not
really have any programming knowledge to
use this tool and mainly it is used for
writing some quick test for demo
purposes advancements with the new
selenium id back in 2017 selenium id
development was completely stopped the
last supported firefox version where
this ide was available as a plugin was
firefox 54 and from 55 onwards the
complete integration point was removed
or it was completely broken however
recently apply tools help revamp much of
the selenium id code they basically
rewrote the whole ide code and then now
they have released a new version under
the apache 2.0 license and it is
completely managed by the selenium
community now let's look at some of the
features of this now traditionally the
selenium id was only a firefox plugin
however the new ide supports both the
browsers the chrome and the firefox and
thus making it cross browser so before
even we start looking at the other
features of the selenium id i would like
to show you how do we install this
firefox plugin or the chrome extension
so for that let me go to my chrome
browser so in the chrome words browser
what i'll simply do is i'll search for
selenium id for chrome so then let's go
to this chrome.google.com
and here you will see it as an extension
selenium id so go ahead click on add to
chrome so this will add this extension
to your chrome browser so now it says
selenium id has been added to the crew
so how do you make out if it is added so
you can see this particular icon here
which says selenium id so this is the
way you can go ahead and install it on
the chrome now on the firefox i have
already installed it since we want to
use the firefox as a browser for all the
demos in this video so here again you
can see the selenium id so if i click on
this ide it is going to open a window
for me and the first window when it
opens it says either open a new project
or open an existing project or simply
you can start recording a new test case
in which case it creates a default
project for you first so what i will do
is i will say open an existing project
and i've already got a project created
so let me go to my folder where i have
this project so i have this project
created and i've opened it i also have a
simple test case written now what this
test case does is let me show you here
it simply goes to google.com and then
here what i'm doing is i'm searching for
selenium hq documentation and then i
click on this site which says
seleniumhq.org and docs so which should
take us to this particular website where
the documentation is available so this
is a simple script which i have tried to
write it in this id so let's keep both
this windows open and let's go back to
our presentation to see the first
feature of this selenium id the first
feature what it says is improved locator
functionality what are locators so these
are nothing but the techniques used for
locating your web elements on your
website now for example in our
example here now the type here the type
which says name equal to q so name equal
to q is a locator now this is a locator
of what initially if you saw i went to
google.com and this is the search button
which i used right the search text and
then i said enter so this is nothing but
your web element for which the locator
is name equal to queue now what happens
in ide is when you record it it has
taken the attribute name and it has
recognized this particular web element
using this attribute however it also has
a feature wherein it also records its
multiple locators available for that
particular web element for example it
also has a css locator it has an expat
locator now how does it help here say
for example tomorrow this particular
attribute name right for the search box
if it changes then what id does is when
you execute this test script it falls
back on your other locators mentioned
here in the structure and then if none
of this locators work only then the test
case is going to go and fail not
otherwise so how does this help this
helps to make the test cases more robust
otherwise having just one locator there
is high possibility the test case might
break or become pretty brittle as in
when the web elements change their
attributes so this is what the locating
techniques are and that is how they have
improved the locator techniques in the
uh functionality in the new id now
what's the next one parallel execution
is possible with this new id so the
first id the traditional one the
parallel execution was not possible
however this is a new feature which has
been added so we will be looking in
detail how to work with this parallel
execution later in this video next is
you can add control statements in your
scripts now what are these control
statements like if else while loops for
each loops and even the switch case the
earlier ide also had this provision but
you had to install a plugin to enable
the use of this control statements and
now with this new id it is available out
of box automatically waits for page to
load in any automation synchronization
between your application under test and
your automation scripts is very
important your script should not run
faster than your application otherwise
your scripts are going to start failing
so it is necessary to have enough flow
times on the operations
of your web elements and also enough
load times on your page now this low
time ensures that all the elements of
your web pages and the page itself is
loaded completely before even a single
line of script is run this new id takes
care of providing that enough uh wait
time and also you have a global set
speed option which you can
use to control your execution of your
scripts so that is something which i
will show you now so if i go back to
this so can you see this clock icon here
so it says test execution speed so what
you can do is right now it is set to the
fastest so i can actually control the
execution speed here so right now i've
just kept it a little slower so let's
see how our test scripts run so you will
be able to see a remarkable difference
when i slow down the complete speed of
this so now do you see how slow it is
initially when i ran it you are unable
to see what i entered in the search
field of the google right so now it's
clearly taking time on each of the steps
which we have mentioned there so now it
is executed successfully so next it
supports embedded code you can run a
simple java javascript from your test
script right and how do you run that by
using a simple command called as execute
now let's see how do we do that so let's
take the same example here now after
clicking this okay so this is our id so
what i will do is i'll first execute
this test case and then in the end where
i will show you how do we add a single
javascript and do some function so
let me get the speed back to a little
normal because we do not want to waste
too much time so i'll just play the
script once so now we are in the
selenium documentation now if you look
at this page this is a pretty long one
so now i'm going to write a simple
javascript wherein i scroll down towards
the end of this page that's all i'm
going to do now for me to do that what i
can do is in my script itself i can just
add another line here okay here i will
say add a new command
here i'll say execute script which is my
command and what is the script which i
want to execute it's a java script which
i'm going to write here i'll say window
dot scroll by and i'm just going to
mention some coordinates here start from
zero and i'll say one five zero zero
okay this is all my code is and now i'll
simply run this test again let's see
what happens so it's going to the
documentation now it's clicked on the
link okay let's move down do you see
this initially it was right here on the
top of the page and once the javascript
was executed it brought me somewhere to
the middle of this page that is how you
can insert snippets of javascript and it
has to be in context with your currently
selected window okay and that's how you
run it all right let's go back to our
ppt okay what's the next feature so
every ide has a debugger which allows
step execution adding of breakpoints now
apart from just having a breakpoints or
adding the step execution there is
another feature which it provides called
i will show you that which is called as
pause and exception so let's close this
window and let's just keep this id
window open here right so can you you
see here pause button it says pause on
exception so what it does is if you
enable this button okay and when you're
running the script so if at all there
happens to be an exception in your
script it stops the execution at that
particular exception field and we will
see this in detail when we look at
complete debugger for the id can be
integrated in ci since you can execute
scripts from command line right we also
talked about the parallel execution and
you can also export the scripts to any
of the programming language you want so
since you can do that these scripts can
be run from command line and hence they
can also be integrated with your maven
project and through jenkins you can run
it and that's how you achieve your ci
working principle of selenium id
selenium id works on a very very simple
principle one is the recording it
records user interactions with the
browser and which forms basically your
id script and using this id script which
is a recorded script you execute the
script and verify and monitor for its
stability and success rate and thirdly
what you can do is you can simply save
your recorded script for your future
runs or regression testing and these
scripts can be saved either in the form
of an id project itself or you can also
export these test scripts into the form
of a javascript or your ruby scripts or
even the web driver scripts now let's
look at the components of this id
interface itself the first one is the
menu bar so let's go back to our id
window so here in the menu bar what you
can see is is a project name so either
you can edit the project name here or
you can simply create a new project open
an existing project and save the current
project so these are all the options
available and since we have already
created a project here i will not be
showing how to create a new project so
that we can do it little later now next
one is the toolbar so this is the
toolbar what we have here for the id now
there are multiple components in the
toolbar so let's see one by one so it
says run all test now if you have
multiple test cases written okay so this
is an option where all the tests can be
run one after the other this is to run
your current test which the focus is on
so currently our focus is on search test
so if i click on this button it is going
to execute the search test for you ide
has this debugger option where you can
do a step execution right you can do
step by step execution using this option
we'll see how to do that for example
let's say we start from here okay and i
click on this so what it does is
basically it has just executed the first
step for me so let's keep this side by
side so that we can observe the complete
execution now if i go and press on this
again step over current command so that
is the next command it is going to
execute now it says type into this all
right so now you can see the selenium hq
documentation okay then again i say step
send keys which it basically it said
enter and then it is going to click on
that documentation which it did and now
we have a script written which scrolls
down on this particular page so let's
execute that and that is what it is so
this is how the step execution happens
so let's close this window and let's
come back to our id window then we have
buttons here where you can say record or
you can stop recording okay then you can
pause the execution and then there are
other options available for disabling
breakpoints so basically you can add
breakpoints any barrier so for example
if i want to add a breakpoint on the
click here so what i have to just do is
i have to just click here so this adds a
breakpoint and if you want to remove all
the spray point you just say disable
those breakpoints so when you run the
script even though you have a breakpoint
available here for that particular run
your breakpoint will be disabled and
your execution will not stop at this
point and let's enable them for now and
what we will do is we'll just run the
script until there so now it has stopped
here at this click now from here either
you can execute the rest of the test
case by just clicking on this run button
or you can stop the execution okay so
for now what we'll do is we'll just stop
the execution so once you stop the
execution you will see that this is in
red which means that this particular
line was not executed or it failed
either of the things because you have
aborted at this particular line and the
rest of the things what you see in green
it shows that all these test steps have
been executed successfully so what is
our next component let's come back here
so we saw the menu bar here we saw the
toolbar we saw start and stop of
recording address bar now what is this
address bar so this address bar is where
you actually write your url from where
you want to start your recording and as
in when you start writing more and more
test cases it keeps a complete history
of all the websites which you are
working on next then we have a test
script editor box which is this so let
me just minimize this little bit okay
this is nothing but your test script
editor box and this is where all your
script steps are all your interactions
are recorded now there are four
attributes in this okay can you see a
command now command is nothing but the
actual operation or the action performed
on your web element so there are
multiple actions you can perform like in
this case we have something called as
open we have got type we have got send
keys and we have got clicks so these are
all the selenium commands which are
available and then we have something
called as target now this target is
nothing but the web element on which you
want to perform the action and now this
target as i said earlier also it is
identified by multiple locating
techniques and if you click on any of
this like we looked at the name here now
similarly the website which we are
clicking on if you look at it there are
multiple locating techniques which are
available here so the one right now
which is being used is the css
identifier you can also have
xpath here which is a relative x bar so
these are all the locating techniques
and this is where which is applied on
the target value so value is an optional
field so you can send any value to your
web element for example in this case
where we are sending the value which is
our text which is
selenium hq dot documentation so this is
the value which i want to send it to as
a search text to my google.com and then
comment or the description so here you
can mention any description about that
particular line which you have recorded
for example i can say here sending
search text to the google search input
box and this gets recorded here against
your
instruction now let's look at the test
case pane now test case pane that is
here so if you look here now it contains
all the test cases which you have
recorded now there are multiple things
here one is your tests so i can always
go ahead and create another say uh test
case two okay i can add a few more test
case here test case three so all these
test cases are here now i can also have
a test suite now there is already test
suite which i have created which is
called the google suite and now if i
want to add test cases under this what i
can do is i can just say add tests and
now i can add any of this test which i
just created under this test suite so
say i have selected the first three and
i've added it so we have test suite we
have tests here and then executing so
executing is basically it shows that
particular test case which is currently
in the execution mode so whichever test
case we run you will see all the test
cases listed here which have been
executed at that point of time that is
your test case pane and then we have
test log and reference this is a very
important window which you need to be
aware of now here this is a running lock
so as in when you are going to run your
test cases the every instruction the
every test step as and when it runs it
is going to log here whether it is
passed whether it has failed whether the
command was executed properly or not and
this is how it records it's a running
law also there is something called as
reference tag now for example just go
ahead and ah let's select one of this
command which you have written here so
which is send keys now this reference it
will show you the complete description
of the command and how to use that
command so say for click it says
references click locator clicks on the
target element it gives you a complete
detail of what exactly the command does
let's create a test script now for say
amazon.com let's go back to our ide what
we will do is we'll create a completely
new project so let i'll click on the
create new project are you sure you
would like to without saving it yes
proceed further and let's give the name
as amazon project now in this new
project what i will do is i will say
i'll add a test and my test name is
search iphone now basically what is the
use case which i'm going to automate so
i will launch amazon.com and i will
search for iphones and once i get the
iphones let's verify the title of that
particular page now just the simple
steps we'll go ahead and do that so for
that first what i need to do is i need
to enter the url now this url needs to
be a fully formula so for that what i
will do i'll first launch amazon.in on
any browser i'll just copy this url and
i can close this browser window and in
this url address space i would say
amazon.com and i'll say enter and now i
would click on this recording button
which says start recording so once i do
this what it does is it launches the web
page with amazon.com and from there i
can start recording my script so let's
do that i'll say record it so
let me just keep this window side by
side so that you can see what is
happening on the id window here now here
what i will do is i'll click on the
search and i'll say iphone and i will
click on the search button and here i
will also click on this best seller once
i'm in this window i'll say right click
now when your selenium id is in the
recording mode you will get this option
here it says selenium id and there are a
lot of options here which you can select
now for this particular moment what i
want to do is i want to assert the title
so i'll just put an assertion pointer
for assert title and then i will close
my browser window now let's see what are
all the commands which it has recorded
let's go one by one right so it is done
it is opening the amazon dot in it is
setting the window size fine it clicked
on the to search window button and then
iphone is what we are searching and then
it said submitted it's basically
clicking on that button and then we said
we also want to open the bestseller link
and here is our asset title right so
it's a very simple test so let's go
ahead and execute this now since i also
have a close command here this script is
going to execute so fast that you will
not be able to make out all the steps
what we have written so for that what i
will do i will comment out the slide now
how do you comment out any command here
just select the command and can you see
here enable and disable command just
click on it so now your command is
disabled also what i will do is i will
reduce the execution speed so that you
should be able to see exactly what is
happening so let's go ahead and execute
this test first so i'll say run current
test okay i have not stopped the
recording so that is the first thing
after closing the window i also need to
click on the stop recording now your
script is ready to be executed so let's
go and run the current script again i'll
just bring this side by side so that you
can see each of these commands being
executed here okay it has searched for
the iphone it's clicked on the best
sellers and it has done the title
assertion now if you look at the log
here as i said see every step as in when
it was executed it has been logged here
can you see here and it puts an ok and
it color coded in green which says that
this particular command was executed
successfully now let's go ahead now this
is what we did by simply recording all
the steps from the browser now one more
thing what we will do is say i want to
continue recording here right i'm not
completed my test case so what you can
still do here is you can come towards
the end of the script and press on
record button again and then you can
continue recording from here now say for
example after the best sellers what we
have got say i want to click on
say hot releases hot new releases so i
do that okay it says it has recorded the
click and then i want to stop the
recording just the another step is what
i wanted to add now it has stopped the
recording so can you see this new line
which has got added so that means you
really need not restart recording all
the steps again if you want to add
something in the middle of your script
you can always go towards the end of the
script or anywhere in between and you
can add more commands there or you can
record anywhere in between the script
and that is how this does so let's go
ahead and again execute this then i will
show you another feature of this okay
it's done the title assertion now and it
is also clicked on hot new releases done
now let's say for example i need to add
another command here now instead of
going ahead and using this recording
what i will do is i will manually add
certain command here say for example
let's go to this amazon website and say
you want to click on this cart so let me
add a command manually here so what is
my command my command is click and then
what is that i want to click i need to
identify that web element for that i can
use this here which says select the
target in the page so i click on that
and i simply select this target which is
my cart and that is all i need to do so
my command is written there so i'll just
simply go ahead and execute this again
let's see what happens so let me close
this window here okay let's run this
test cases bring this window to the site
so now you can see one by one the
instructions being executed okay the
iphone has been searched the best seller
has been clicked assert title so it says
your shopping cart is empty so that
means it is successfully able to click
on the cart so now with using id there
are multiple things you can do you can
simply record your script while you are
running your test case you can add a
command all by yourself you can stop
recording anywhere and again restart
from the same point now we have our
complete test script ready now let's go
ahead and save this so how do you save
this simply go here and save your
complete project so all the projects
from the id are saved as dot site file
so let's name this as amazon project and
i will save it so if i show you in my
finder how it looks like this is the
project we created so it always stores
with the file extension dot sid right
that was selenium id now also i said you
can export test cases into multiple
format so search iphone is my test case
so what i can do is i can just say right
click and i can say export now right now
you can see only three options it says
java j unit javascripts and python
however the older ide had multiple
options of export which had even the web
driver scripts and also the javascripts
this is still in works and they would be
adding more support for other
programming languages here so but for
now the only options what is available
to us is java junit javascript and the
python so let's go ahead and export this
into java j unit so it's going to simply
save it as dot java file let me go here
in the id test i will save this file so
if you go back to my finder you can find
our search iphone test dot java you can
open the java file you can you can see
here it's a simple junit test it is
exported into so if you have an eclipse
ide you can use this test and execute it
from your eclipse side selenium commands
selenium commands can be broadly
classified into three action commands
accessors and assertions what are action
commands action commands are the
commands which interact directly with
the web elements on your application so
let's look at what these commands are so
if we go back to our previous example
where we had written a test script for
amazon.n so if you look at all these
things like open set window size click
type so these are all nothing but called
as action commands and if you go here
you can see let me do one thing so let
me just come to a blank line and now
let's look at the list of commands so
you have a whole list of commands here
listed in the alphabetical order like
add selection there are multiple asset
commands which is made available to you
and then there are set of commands where
you say click or click at a particular
location closing the browser using a
debugger command double click drag and
drop echo i'll just explain how to use
an echo command so this is a command
which is not or used on your web element
but something which you want to say
display on your console and then there
are if else statements which are used as
commands here then you have something
called as execute script for you to
execute any say javascript or any
different script which you want to
execute from your test script here and
then you have few mouse commands here
open which is what we use for opening a
new url pause and so on so there are
multiple commands which you can look at
and try to use this commands in your
script so these are all called as the
action commands so let's go ahead and
use this echo command and see what it
does so now in the same script what i
will do is towards the end of the script
i'll just add this command i'll say echo
and say i want to just display a message
saying that this is the end of the
script execution that is all i want to
do now i'll just go ahead and run this
and what we want to observe here is how
this particular message what we have
given here is displayed on the console
in the log so now if you observe here so
go to this last statement what we have
so it says after clicking on the card it
said echo this is the end of the script
so this is what we displayed and using
the command echo okay so this is how you
can use the echo another feature here
what you can do here is now say for
example i just added a simple echo
statement here now for me to execute
that what i did was i executed the
complete script you really need not do
that always instead of that what i can
do is i can just come to this particular
line i can just say right click and i
can say play from here so what it does
is from this point it is going to play
the script for me and not right from the
beginning of the script so i'll show you
how now with this command if you look
here see it started running the script
here it says running search iphone and
then it executed only one command which
says echo this is the end of the script
so this is also possible to do with the
id accessors accesses are the selenium
commands that examine the state of an
application and store the results in a
variable so these are those commands
which allow the user to store say
certain values into your user defined
variables and these stored values can be
later on used either to create
assertions or you can have some
verification points created so let's see
some of the store commands in action so
i have few store commands here which
i'll be demoing so first one is a store
so simply using a store command you can
store any kind of user defined messages
in a variable and then after that you
can either use it for displaying it on
your console or you can do some
assertions with that similarly store
title so you can to store the title of
any of the web page under test then
store text so store text is basically
used to uh capture the text attribute of
any web element on your web page and
store it in a variable use it as an
assertion point store value so store
value again is uh used to store the
value attribute of any web element like
so you have lot of web elements on the
web page and say one of the attributes
is what you want to do an assertion on
so what you can do is you can use the
store value command here get the value
attribute of your web element and store
it in a variable so let's see all these
commands in action so let's go back to
the same example so we have this amazon
test script example so what i'll do is
say instead of using amazon let's do one
thing so let's create another test case
itself so i'll go here i'll say add new
test and i'll name this test as accessor
test and we will use the same amazon
site here i'll say click on start
recording keep this window side by side
so first we will look at store title so
simply what i need to do is go to this
amazon site which we have launched right
click on this go to the selenium id and
you have multiple options here so go
ahead and select store title so once i
click on that it is going to ask me the
variable name where i want to store the
title of this page so let's create a
variable here i'll say var title and
i'll say okay done now come back to your
ide all right so i will stop the
execution here now i have the store
title command i created a variable
called var title and i'm storing the
actual title into this variable so let's
also display this on our console so i'll
add a command here echo and in target
how do i use the variable now this is
the way to use it i'll say dollar and in
flower braces i will give the variable
name which i have defined earlier so it
is what i dle title okay so this is all
my scriptures where i'm storing the
title of the webpage and i'm displaying
it in my console or the lock so now
there are some extra commands which gets
added here now because we are doing the
recording on that so whatever the mouse
movements happen it is going to record
we do not need this so i will go ahead
and delete this particular command so
lets close this window and execute this
test first so the script has executed
successfully but let us go and see
whether did we get the title displayed
on the console yes so it it did open the
amazon site it has set the window size
it captured the title here in this line
and then after assigning it to the
variable we said echo and that variable
name and it is displayed as the title of
the page so now similarly let's go ahead
and let's see how do we use the store
text command now for store text i need
an use case here say for example
what about this cut let's say we want to
display the text of this particular
element now the text of this element is
cut so now instead of again going and
re-recording all the steps i will simply
manually add this command so now after
displaying the title okay so let's go
ahead here and i will say store text and
in store text i need to pick the text
from this web element cart so what i
will do is i'll use this target select
target and i will select this particular
element which is cut after this i need
to create a variable where it can be
stored so i'll say where cart text now
similarly i will also display it using
echo comma echo dollar in the flower
braces i'll say where car text so let's
execute this and then let's look at the
other command so i'll just say i'll
close this window again run this test so
now look at this log lines so our last
statements was storing the title and
displaying the title after that we added
store text okay so here is the command
it said it is executed successfully it
was able to retrieve the text from the
element cart and the text retrieved was
cart and which is what got displayed
with the echo statement on our console
so now let's move to our next store
command which is store value now as i
said store value for us to use that
particular web element should have the
attribute value so first let's examine
which element we can take and display
the value now on the same website i have
the search button so i will right click
on this and i say inspect element now
look at all the attributes of this
element it is of type input it has a
class name it is of type submit and also
it has this value attribute which is
gogo and this is exactly what i want to
retrieve and print so we will be using
the search button now similarly same
thing what i will do here i'll go ahead
add a command here as a store value same
way i will select the target as i select
target from page i will click on the
search button all right so here it has
taken the target here in the value i
will mention the variable name where i
want to store the value so i'll say
where button and value and similarly i
will say echo and i will print the value
of this variable which is dollar where
btn value let's go ahead and execute
this and say run current test so it has
taken the title it has printed the value
on the line 7. so it says store value on
this particular element and the value
was stored in the variable where btn
value so that command was successful and
the value actually which was got stored
and which we retrieved using echo
statement was geogo and that's exactly
what we had here if you want to check
again go here to inspect element the one
which is highlighted so as we said the
value is go and that's exactly got
printed on our console now apart from
this i also said there is a simple
command which is just store so let's use
that also now after all this here i will
say store and say we want to just store
a user message i would say a target as
all store commands demod and this
message i will capture it in a variable
say that string this is just a text and
then like i did it in the other that
string and i'll say echo and the
variable name so now if we
close this and one way to do it is
execute the complete test so which will
execute all our store commands and also
the last line is this the line number
nine in the log which says the store
command which we use to store the text
all store commands demod and that is
also displayed using the x so all the
store commands we have demoed
successfully now let's close this window
and go back to our presentation so this
is all about the accessor command now
what do we have after accessor so we
have something called as assertions now
what is an assert so assertion is
nothing but it verifies the current
state of an application with an expected
state so this is something where you
compare your actual result with the
expected result now assertions are of
three different type one is assert
verify and wait for now what does assert
does when the assert command is executed
and if it fails right the test stops
immediately after this statement so if
you are asserting say
a title of a page and if you find that
the title of page is not as expected as
soon as it finds that failure your rest
of the test case test is not going to
run and it's going to immediately stop
the test and also it is going to flag
the test cases fake what is verify
verify something where this selenium id
it locks that particular assertion as
fail however it would continue with the
rest of the steps in the test case and
then at the end of it the your overall
test case is flagged as fake that is
what verified us so verify is called a
soft assertion whereas assert here is
called as hard assertion why it is
called harder session because as soon as
an assert statement fails the complete
test execution stops at that statement
whereas in soft hazard what happens is
after the failure happens the test
continues with the rest of the steps and
continue it completes its execution and
then flags the test cases failure and
when is this usually used in cases like
as the same example say if you are
asserting a title you really do not want
the test case execution to stop even if
there is a failure why because none of
your steps are going to be dependent on
this assertion point and this is where
you will require a soft hassle wait for
wait for something which waits for a
certain condition to be true after that
it proceeds to your further steps so if
the condition goes false here for
whatever say if you are waiting for an
element to appear on the web page and if
that element does not appear the test
fails however it carries forward and
completes the test by executing the rest
of the steps and then flags the complete
test case as a failure which will be
something similar to a software so let's
see all these things in action let's go
back to our id we will create another
test case here so i'll say assert test
now for this what's the example we can
take so first for assert title let's do
the assert title on amazon itself and
let's change the same test case to
verify and see how this test case behave
now for this i will launch the recorder
with the same amazon dot in okay my
recorder is launched now simply i will
go to this website and i'll say right
click selenium ide and i'll say assert
title then i will stop the recording now
here i will remove this command which
has got added which i don't need so this
is my asset title now we have already
seen a third title passing in couple of
our other examples now i want to show
you a failure on ourselves so for that
what i will do i will modify this actual
type so here in the last line i'll just
remove this amazon dotting so now
ideally this test case is going to fail
first because the title which it is
expecting and what it is comparing
against are not the same first let's
execute this
well i also need to show some statements
after this so what i will do is let's
add few more statements here let me
start the recording here again say after
asserting the title we want to go and
click on this bestseller and then i will
close this now let's execute this stop
the recording and execute this test now
do you see this assert title is in red
that means it has failed the validation
here so you see here in the log it says
open the site done set window size done
when it comes to azure title it says
actual value was something different and
it did not match with what you are
trying to look for assert test ended
with one error now after this assert
please observe that there are no other
statements which got executed this test
stopped right away after this failure
this is called as hard assert now let's
go ahead and change this assert title to
verify title so simply what i will do in
the command itself instead of assert
i'll say verify title and now let's
execute this and see what happens now
let me close this window first and then
i'll say run test running assert test
amazon dot in was open window size was
set verify title failed because the
titles were different because we have
modified that however do you see this
fourth line being executed click on link
test bestseller and click on close now
since i it was a very fast execution and
i closed the browser probably was you
were not able to see the best sellers
clicked here that is fine but in the log
we can see here that the steps 4 and 5
got executed even after the title verify
title step fit and if you compare it
with the previous example where assert
title failed the two lines after that
the line 4 where we are clicking on the
best seller and closing the browser are
not getting executed so this is the main
difference between the verify title and
the asset title so now let's look at
wait for how do we use wait for now for
wait for i want to look at some kind of
website where it would load an element
dynamically after a while so for that i
have a website here let's let's create a
new test again let's go to the tests
pane i will say assertion test and now
uh let's go to a browser let me open
a new window and there is a demo site
which i want to use so let me search for
that and then i will use that url so
i'll say internet i'm going to use the
dynamic loading do we have here yes
dynamic loading page element rendered
now so if you look at this website when
i press on the start button right after
a while this hello world text is going
to appear on this webpage so in our use
case what we will do we will launch this
website we will click on the start
button and then we will put an assert on
this text using wait for let's do that
so let's go here let me copy this this
is the one let me say control c and in
my new test i'll say control v and then
i'll say start recording so it's going
to launch this let's close the previous
windows now in this i'm just going to
click on start so that is going to get
recorded done and now while the
recording is still on i will add a
command here for wait for so i'll say
wait for element visible that is exactly
what we are saying right so wait for is
used until for a condition and until
that condition is true so i am saying
here please wait for this particular
element which i'm going to give it in
target until it is visible now the
target is i'm just going to select the
target from this web page itself so i'll
say select target and i'm going to
select this particular text come back
here to your id so wait for the element
to be visible what is the element to be
visible is this hello volta hello world
text and then you need to give a value
here now what is this value since we are
using wait for we need to mention a
timeout so we have to tell basically to
id that okay wait for say one second two
seconds or three seconds whatever it is
required and that timeout value is needs
to be mentioned here so and this is in
milliseconds so what i will say is i'll
say so let's fail this test case first
so i'll use a little lesser time mark so
i'll say three thousand so that is three
thousand milliseconds which is three
seconds that is it and then we can say
so what we'll do here is we'll add an
assert so i will say assert text now
what is the other text i'm going to do i
need to look for the same element so
i'll simply say select target this one
and what is that i'm going to assert
with i'm going to assert with the same
text so i'll just copy this text and
i'll put it in the value there's another
way of doing that which we have done it
previously so i can just go here do a
right click go to selenium id and i can
say assert text which is basically going
to give me the same command so let me
just go ahead and remove one of them
either of them you can remove okay so
let's stop the recording i will not
close this browser because i want you to
see how the dynamically loaded element
behaves and will go ahead and execute
this so i'll say stop recording and say
execute this test now it's here all
right so it's waiting okay it just
failed now see this so it says wait for
element visible after that the value we
have mentioned is 3000 that is wait for
three seconds which was not enough
because and it failed with saying that
unable to locate the element within the
timer period now let's go ahead and
change it to a passing value so i will
say 10 000 here which is 10 seconds so
let's close this
and let's again execute this bring this
to the side so that we can see okay it
is waiting on that wait for element now
look at the problem here what we have
done is we have closed the website and
after that we have added the assert text
so this is a mistake what we have done
and hence though it is found that
element here for wait for what did it do
it went ahead and closed the window and
after that it's definitely not going to
find the assertive right so that's the
mistake what we have done so let's go
ahead and debug this so what we will do
after this wait for element we want this
assert to be put after that we don't
need this click content because this was
an additional step which got added
delete it and then close okay fine so
now let's go ahead and rerun this so
i'll say run current test i'll move this
to a side okay it's waiting all right
done so now it is able to do an assert
text on this all right so this is how
you use the wait for key features of
selenium id let's look at the first
feature reusability of test scripts so
many of the test scripts have test steps
that involves signing into an
application or creating an account like
for example a login screen is a very uh
key example in this case where whenever
you are testing your application first
you need to log in and then perform any
other test so now it's going to be a
redundant or a waste of time to recreate
the login steps again and again for each
and every test case so we do not want to
definitely do that so as we know since a
record and replay tool does not have
enough capability of writing
common test cases or a common functions
and calling those common factions like
our regular selenium web driver has
however what id is done is it has given
us a provision to run one script from
another script so what basically what we
do here is especially for a login we
write one test case which is going to
log into your application and call this
test case in the other test cases so
let's take a a look at how this works so
for that let's go to our id so in this
id
we'll do one thing let's go ahead and
create a new project so let's say login
project in this project i will create a
new test case we'll call it as login
test let's say add now in this login
test i need to give a url now for this
purpose i will be using again a demo
site so first let me
launch a demo site here file new window
and i will say the demo site go dot uk
okay this is a simple demo site which
has a login functionality right so here
i will go to the login screen now this
also allows me to add few users and
using the same users we can go ahead and
do the login now coming back to our
login page so this is the url which i
need to launch which is going to give us
username and password we will use to
login into this application so give this
url here and say start recording move
this window here for recording and this
here now what is the first step we want
to record we want to come here click on
the username and i'll say user1 okay and
i'll say
passwordpwd1 and i will click on test
login and then what we will do is we
will assert this text so here i'll say
right click selenium id assert text
that's it and then i will close the
browser okay this is all my test is now
come back to your id let's see if there
are any unnecessary commands which it
has taken okay click type all done and
now for the time being i'm going to
comment out this close comment because i
want the browser to be still open so
that we can see the actual test
execution properly till the end of the
script this is the login test case now
simply if i run this let's execute this
let me execute this and show stop the
recording and execute this test case so
it typed user one it typed pwd which is
my password here and then clicked on the
button and then definitely it was the
wrong password so it gave me fail
docking so this is fast fantastic
however this is with one value i have
used it but this is a function which i
want to use it every time and also a
probable use case i might have is that i
might need to login with a different
user id and password and apart from that
even just to test this login test page i
would want to test with multiple user id
and password like valid credentials and
invalid credential now for that purpose
what we will do is we will parameterize
this name that is user id and the
password and how do i parameterize it
simply go here instead of giving a hard
coded value here what you can do is just
say use any variable name here and we'll
define this variable somewhere else so
i'll say username this is the variable
similarly for my password in my value
field instead of a hard coded value i'll
say dollar and i will say password now i
cannot run this program as it is because
there is this variable is not defined in
the login.test what i will do now is i
will create my actual test case so i'll
say here i'll say invalid credential as
my test case and i'll say add now here
is where i will assign values for my
variable now which are these variables i
need to use username and password so i
need to assign some value here and then
call this function login test so let's
do that in this video previously we also
saw how do we use user variables and how
do we assign value by using the store
command so i'm going to say store and
then my target is going to be the actual
value so
user1 and where is that i'm going to
pass this to my variable username so
let's just check once if the variable
name is username yes all right done now
i have done the username now i need to
pass the password so i again i'll say
store the actual password which is pwd1
in my case and what is the variable i
need to use here i have to use password
because that's the variable which we
have used in login test here and then
after that i need to use a command which
is called as run now what this run
command does is run and whatever target
you give which is basically your another
test case it is going to run the test
case now in our case our test is login
test this is all our test case is going
to be okay so what is that we did we do
in this test case we created a variable
username and password and assigned the
actual username and password and then we
are just calling this login test and in
this login test this username and
password will get passed which will be
user1 and pwd1 and then it will execute
this test with the or with the value
which we have passed to this variable so
now which test case we need to run the
invalid credential so let's go ahead
close this window and execute this test
executed so now look at the log of this
invalid credential test see running
login test called by invalid credential
before that it said store this value
store user 1 in the value username that
is your variable this is this line and
then the password then it says run login
test so it called the login test
functionality and in the login test we
have all this clicking on the password
field clicking on the username and then
asserting the text and that's exactly
what is done here this is how you use it
so now let's write one more test here
for the same login test so
let me add another test i'll say valid
credentials and let's say add now same
thing i will do here i'll say command
store my target will be now i'll say
user3 value will be username right okay
now second command will be again storing
this time it is for the password my
password is pwd3 and
the variable name is password and same
thing i'll just call run and my login
test that's it now similarly let's run
this test and see what happens now this
test is going to fail why let me close
this window i don't need this why did
this test case fail because my assertion
point let's go to the tests i'll show
you my assertion point in login test is
look for failed login however we created
a test case for valid credentials right
because our valid credentials were said
that the login was successful which did
not match with what we were asserting
which is fine right so we just wanted to
see whether we can write a test case
with valid credentials and invalid
credentials and this is how you do that
by passing the variables through your
test case to your actual test case the
next feature is the debugger in the id
like every other id offers a debugger
functionality so does selenium id so
let's look at what are the different
functions available for us in the
debugging so there are multiple
functionalities which the selenium ide
offers us so one is called as the step
execution so for us to look at how each
of these debugging techniques works what
i'll do is let's go ahead and create a
new test script so let's go to our id
and i will create a new test case so
i'll say new test case let's use
facebook login this time so i'll say fb
login test or we'll just say fb test so
now for this fb test i would go ahead
and use the facebook login page so i'll
just copy this url paste it here and
then i will minimize this other firefox
window and i will launch the recorder
now so i'll click on start recording now
let's keep this side by side and what is
that we're going to do here is let's do
a simple login functionality so i'll
just use some email id here so i'll say
my user at gmail.com this is just a
dummy user id and password values and
i'll say password as password1 then i'll
click on login button let's stop the
recording here so let's read the script
once whether it has got everything
whatever we need okay it has launched
facebook it clicked on email id there's
a double clicks here because i happen to
click twice on the email id field so
what i'll do i'll remove one we don't
need it and then i'm typing the keys
which is myuser.gmail and then i'm
clicking on the password field typing
the password and clicking on the login
button and then once i do that okay so
i'm going to get this pages the password
you have entered is incorrect so let it
be so we will use the script until here
and check out some of the login options
okay so we have completed writing of the
script let me go ahead and close this
window now first thing what we will do
is we'll just simply execute the script
so we have to just say run current test
so it's going to log in your facebook it
will enter my user at gmail it will
enter the password it will log in and
that's about it so now your script is
executed now let's go into the debug
mode as we said there are multiple
options for debugging what is the first
option let's see so first option we have
is something called a step execution so
what the step execution does is from
your script you can execute all the
steps one after the other so you can
basically control the execution of each
step and how you do that what you have
to do is just go and click anywhere so
let's start from the beginning let's
close this window of our previous run
and there is an option here which says
step over current command so when you
click on this what it does is it
basically executes your first line where
your cursor was and it stops immediately
after that so if you look here it has
launched the facebook page which says
open the url facebook and then let's go
ahead and just do the simple step
execution again i will click on that it
is going to execute this command where
it set the window size to certain value
again i will do a step execution now
observe what happens here it clicked on
this email field do you see the cursor
there now let's do the next step again
again i will do step over current
command now the current command was it
entered my user at gmail you can see it
on the left side here now it will be
more visible again i will do a step
execution it is going to click on the
password field now it is going to enter
the password and now the last step is
it's going to click on the login button
and with this all our commands are
executed and this is how you do the step
execution and now where is this useful
say if you've got a very long test case
written and you want at certain point
you want to start doing the step
execution to see where your test cases
fail probably one of your web element
you entered is wrong or probably the
text which you are entered is wrong so
for you to debug such cases you can use
this step over current command
functionality so what's our next command
break points so there are break points
which you can insert in your script okay
so let's close this execution and let's
come back to our script so what i will
do is first let's add a breakpoint how
do you add a breakpoint say for example
we want to add a breakpoint after we
type in our email id so here what i do
is i simply go and click here so once
you click here this is where your
breakpoint is added other way of adding
breakpoint is you can right click on any
command and you can use this toggle
breakpoint so if there is no breakpoint
it adds the breakpoint and for you to
remove it you can simply go and select
the toggle breakpoint again so now i've
added a single breakpoint now what you
need to do is once you execute this once
you say run test what it will do is it
will come till here till your breakpoint
it will execute all the commands before
that and it stops or pauses your
execution at this point okay let's go
ahead and see how it does so what i'll
do is i've added a break point at the
click on password field and i will say
execute this test do you see here it
says paused in the debugger so by adding
breakpoint my test has entered the
debugging mode and where has it stopped
to at the point where i added this
breakpoint so just go back here and see
whether the previous steps have been
executed yes my previous step was adding
this myuser gmail.com into the email
field which it has done and it is paused
here and now from here i can either run
the rest of the tests if i just click on
this run current test what it will do is
it will go ahead and execute all the
steps or even i can do a step execution
from here so say if i want to do a step
execution i'll do this let me minimize
this window a little bit so that you can
see and i'm still again doing that step
execution so it added the password and
after this i'll say just go ahead and
complete the test so it is clicked on
your sign in login button and it is
logged in so this is how you can use the
breakpoint so that is about adding the
breakpoint let's see what's the next
removing the breakpoint so i showed you
so if you want to add a breakpoint you
just click here or you can do a right
click and do toggle breakpoint if you
want to remove the breakpoint just click
again on the same place where it has
added the breakpoint or you can always
do this toggle breakpoint so this is the
way of adding and removing the brick
parts what is the third option disabling
now say for example my test case is a
pretty long one okay so i might have a
multiple breakpoints so say let's add
one breakpoint here at the email and
then before clicking on login let's add
another breakpoint now when i execute
this it is going to stop here and then
again if i say continue execution it is
going to come and stop here so let's do
that first and then i'll show you how
the disable works so let's close this
window again execute this bring this
window here can you see this it's paused
here okay and here now you should be
able to see it now i'll say just run
after this breakpoint do you see here it
is paused after entering the password it
has not clicked on the login button it's
paused at the click and now i'll say
again complete the test so your click on
the login button is done and it is
logged in so it's a little bit slow yeah
now you've got that logged in page at
some point of time while i'm debugging
my test case i would want to just
disable all the breakpoints and not
remove everything for that i have an
option here which says disable
breakpoint so if this button is
highlighted here that means i have
selected disable breakpoint so what this
does is when i execute this test it
ignores all these breakpoints for this
run it ignores this breakpoint until i
have selected this disable breakpoint
button okay so let's see this let me
close this again and i have enabled this
disable breakpoint is what i have
selected i'll just simply go ahead and
run this test case do you see that it
did not stop at this break point it went
ahead and completed the execution why
because i have temporarily disabled it
once i remove the selection and run it
it is again going to stop at the break
points so this is how it works so we saw
adding of requirements removing of
breakpoints and disabling of breakpoints
what is the next one enter debugger by
using play to this point option okay now
another way of doing this is so let's
remove all this breakpoint now for
example like the last time we said we
want to add a breakpoint here so now
instead of doing that what i can do also
do is i can just right click on that
particular command and i can say play to
this point only so when i select this
what happens it acts like a break point
and it comes and pauses at this
particular command where i have said
play till this point so let's try to do
that so let me close this window and
then for say type the password so here
okay i'll say right click play to this
point so it is going to execute all the
steps until the password and it will
stop here can you see this paused in the
debugger so it again enter the debug
mode and now it is stopped at this point
so now there are multiple options now
every time last time what we did we did
a step over and also we said continue
with the rest of the test now what we
will do we'll just stop the execution so
this is also an option available say if
you want to change something here you do
not want to continue with your execution
you can simply go ahead and stop the
execution so we saw how do we use the
play to this point option now debugger
command now all these things whatever we
did now adding the breakpoints this was
done in the id there is also a way of
adding a debugger programmatically and
how do we do that let's see now at the
same place say after entering the
password so here i will insert a command
in this command i'll just say debugger
this is all the command is now what
happens when i execute this test cases
at this point wherever it finds this
debugger command this program enters
into a debug mode and it comes and
pauses the script here let's see this in
action so simply i'll just play the
script let's type the email id it's
typed the password okay it is going a
little slower here okay and there there
you go now it is paused in deeper so
this debugger did the same job as what
we did earlier with the breakpoints now
let's go ahead and just stop the
execution because let's not keep logging
into facebook with invalid username and
id okay so this is how you can use the
debugger command so i will stop the
execution here close this window and
then now let's see the next one let's
close this window so we saw the debug
pause on exception okay this is a very
brilliant feature of this id i'll show
you how it works now let's say let me
remove this command now i do not want
the debugger i'll say delete this
command just click let it be there now
if you look at this what we are doing is
we are identifying these elements like
email password and then clicking on the
login button now say for example say
this click so
let's run this then i'll show you what
it is and i want it to come and stop
here okay so i will execute this all
right so now it is paused here so now
what i will do is the click right so
this is where i am clicking is this
login button so this login button is
identified by some identifier which is
an id now there is a possibility that
tomorrow this particular id might change
or any of the locator might change on
this particular website and if that
happens the first point of failure what
you will see is when you click on this
button because this script will say that
this element is not formed in such cases
if you are using pause on exception that
is here pause an exception what happens
is whenever this script finds an
exception it goes and pauses at that and
enters into a debug mode otherwise what
happens whenever you find an exception
your complete test script will stop
executing because there is an error and
your test case fails instead since we
are in a debugging mode if you choose
this option what happens is if there is
an exception it is going to come get
into the debugger mode and it is going
to pause the execution at that point and
once it pauses what you can do is you
can go and correct it and then continue
your execution so let's see that in
action so now for example the click
button so here the id is you underscore
0 underscore so say i try to change this
let me add 1 here and then if i execute
this this script should fail for me
basically because it is not going to
find this so can you see us trying to
find this id and since this particular
element with this id does not exist this
whole test case should fail firm now as
i said earlier in this video so if by
any chance if one of the element id is
not found so if that is not found it
always falls back into the other locator
techniques and that is what it did in
this case it tried to locate the login
button using some other id and that's
what it says element found with the
secondary locator okay to use it by
default update the test step and to use
it as a primary locator and that is
where the test case pass so let's try to
see if i can make this test case fail in
any way for that let's remove this and
let's try on the email id so what i will
do is let me try to comment this out
remove the debugger and i will add a
command here i'll say insert new command
and in this i will say click and then i
will use the target as id equal to email
now in this case i do not have a
fallback id because i am not using id to
recognize the element rather i added my
own command and i added my own locator
here so now let's try with this and now
instead of this is the right id so what
i will do is i'll just change this id to
something like underscore one so that
this test case fails for me now let me
close this and let's run this test case
and basically this test case should fail
so if you see here in the log it's
saying trying to find the element with
id email underscore one so this id has a
default timer so it will keep trying to
find the element until the timeout value
is completed now there we go so it had
an implicit timeout of 30 000 so that is
30 seconds 30 000 milliseconds which was
30 seconds now after that this test is
filled so this is the scenario we wanted
what happens here is it simply started
executing the moment it found an
exception it completely stopped so as a
tester what you need to do is you need
to go back look for this red lines where
it has failed correct it and then rerun
the whole test now instead of that what
this pause and exception does is let me
click on that so this is what is
selected now what it does is when i
execute this this is going to come and
stop here let's see that so let me close
this and run this program again so run
current test i'll bring this to the side
now see it's trying to find the id since
the timeout is almost 30 seconds we need
to wait until it pauses at this so now
do you see this now it is not exited
from the test it is just at the same
step where it is unable to find this
email field okay and it's saying okay it
failed with an implicit timeout of 30
seconds but now since i'm in the
debugging mode and how did i get into
the debug mode by selecting this option
pause an exception now what i can do is
i can go ahead and change this back to
the actual one and then from here i can
just simply do this i can say run the
test now so now see what it did the
moment i changed that and i said run it
passed and how did it pass because i
gave the right id here and that's
exactly you can do with this departure
control flow statements so in the legacy
id uh these control flow statements were
available as plugin so one had to
install the plugin for you to use any of
this control flow statements however in
the new ide these are available out of
box so let's see what this control
statements are so let's go to my notes
so there are two types of control flow
statements one is conditional branching
and the other one is looping so in
conditional branching we have a regular
if else if nested if else and end and
when we talk about looping there are
multiple loops available one is the
while end loop so how does the while end
loop work the code between the while and
the end is executed until the expression
is true and then we have a do repeat so
do repeat where the commands after the
do will get executed first and then the
condition is checked and this is
evaluated in the if statement times end
so you can specify a number of
iterations you would like a piece of
code to be executed using this loop and
then there is another loop which is a
for each loop so this provides the
ability to iterate over collection
objects like say if you have an array
object with you and you want to say or
traverse through the array and perform
certain operations on each of the array
element so that is possible using the
for each loop so let's go and write a
test script and see how this work so
what i will do is i will demonstrate a
use case for the if else and then for
the looping i have a few test scripts
which i have already written which i
will show you and i will walk you
through them it's a simple counter which
we can use and we will be incrementing
the counter using one of these loops so
we will just see how the loops are to be
used what is the syntax to be used and
how they execute in the id so let's go
to our id now let's minimize this so
this was our previous test case so what
i will do is i will close this project
and open another project so i have
another project here which is called as
control flows so as i said i have few
scripts written for some of the loops
however for the demo use case we will go
ahead and write a new script okay so
i'll say add new test and uh we are
going to be working with a demo site
called calorie calculator so let me name
the test case itself as calorie
calculator test so let's look at what is
our use case now in this use case this
is my use case i am saying go to this
gallery counter website okay so let's
see what that website is i have this
website open here so this is a calorie
calculator website in this website we
are saying if the gender is male then
click on the mail radio button so you
have multiple fields here where you are
accepting the age of a person the gender
of a person the height the weight and
then the activity level of the person
and when when you click on calculate
this is going to give you the number of
calories so for our purpose for our demo
use case what we will do is we will
store the gender to be selected in a
variable say for example i want a gender
female to be selected and then i'm going
to write an if condition here that if
the gender is male right so if the
gender is male then click on the mail
radio button here and then i'm saying
click active from the activity drop down
so there is a drop down called activity
here in this i am going to go and select
active as daily exercise or intense
exercise three to four times a week this
is what i am going to be selecting and
if the gender is female so if the value
passed from the gender is female then
what is that i want to do i want to
click on this radio button female and
select very active intense exercise from
this activity dropped up a very simple
use case so this is what we are going to
write in our test script so let's
minimize this window or we can just
close this window for now we don't need
this and here so how do we start this
test case i need to enter the url so for
me to enter the url let me go to that
copy this url ctrl c minimize this and
control v done so now here i will start
my recording by clicking on the start
recording button so now this url is open
now the first thing what i need to do is
in my test script i need to write a open
command so i'll say open and my target
is what this url done the next command
is as per our use case i want to store
the gender to be selected in a variable
so we will use the store command and
when we use the store command we need to
specify the target so let's say the
target is f and where is that i want to
store i'll create a var gender that's my
variable so i have stored this now what
is the next thing i want to do so once i
have stored this first is i need to put
an if statement because my use case is
if the gender is male and if the gender
is female now since by default the male
is already selected here so let's put an
if condition for this condition if the
gender is female okay so that is exactly
what i am going to do so here i will say
if in the command once i say if in the
target you need to specify the condition
now condition is i want to check for
dollar that's my variable where gender i
want to check if this is equal to f and
how is that i can check i need to use 3
equal to here in double quotes i'm going
to mention f now this is what i have
stored in the variable that gender this
is what i'm going to check so if this is
the condition in the next line now all
the next lines whatever i am going to
mention are the ones which will be
executed if this condition is true now
in the next line what i want is i want
to select this radio button correct so
now what i will do instead of writing
all the commands manually i will now use
a recorder to do that since i'm already
in the recording mode i'll just go to
the url or the website here and i'll go
click on this female so on the right if
you see these steps are getting recorded
and then our use case also said that
from the activity drop down we want to
select very active so now if you look
here all our steps have been recorded so
i clicked on the female radio button and
then we selected the id activity here
which is our activity drop down and then
we clicked on the desired value which is
very active and then you end the if
statement here so but we also want to
add an else statement so instead of
saying end here i will say else so that
means if the gender selected is male
okay what is that we want to do i want
to go and select in the activity field
as active because the mail is already
selected so i'm not going to select it
again and then i will end the if loop by
end statement that is all so this is all
my script is so let's stop the recording
here there are some mouse move mouse up
which i really do not need so what i
will do is i'll just delete this so this
is the simple statement what i need in
the else where i'm saying select so
select is something a command which is
used to select a web element which is
your drop down so you select the drop
down here and once the drop down is
clicked and then you go ahead and click
on this particular target is nothing but
your active daily exercises or intense
this value from the drop down is what
i'm selecting and same same thing what
we did in the if statement so let's
remove these also we don't
mouse move at and mouse up at so all
these statements we don't need so same
thing if i am saying the if statement
says if the gender is f that is female
click on the radio button then go to the
select activity select the activity by
clicking on very active and then end the
loop so this is all our scriptures now
let's go ahead and execute this and see
whether it works so let's minimize this
window and i will simply say execute the
current test let's slow down the
execution speed little bit so that you
can observe what exactly is happening
now i'll say run the current test so the
calorie calculator is open so we are
passing the value f for the gender
correct so that means it entered this
loop you can see here in the log so if
the gender is f which is female yes it
found the condition to be true and then
it clicked on this radio button it went
to the select field which is your
activity drop down it selected the very
active option from here and then it
ended now in the same program what i
will do instead of f let's pass the
value m mail and let's see what happens
and then we will go ahead and execute
this program so let's close this window
again and execute the test script again
so now according to the script we are
not reselecting the radio button because
this is already selected by default and
in this descript if you see now all the
green colored one if you see okay the
open command ran successfully store
commander and successfully it came to
the if condition it checked if the
gender was f or m it found that this
condition is not true so can you see
here all these other statements in the
if are in black color that means these
were not executed instead it came to the
else part and then it executed all the
commands in the else part so this is how
you use a if condition in your selenium
id so let's close this now as i said
there are other looping statements what
we have like while end loop or do repeat
and time set so i have couple of
examples written here let's walk through
that and see so let's take the while
loop first so what happens in this while
loop let's see in this while loop what
i'm basically doing is i have created a
counter and i am counting it from 1 to 5
and then displaying the value of the
counter and i am using a while loop for
that so here it says first i am setting
a counter value to 1 and then i am
saying while the counter value is less
than 5 this is the loop while and end so
whatever commands are within that those
get executed until the condition is true
so this loop will get executed until the
counter becomes 5. so once it sees that
counter is 5 it is going to exit the
loop and just print the value of the
counter it's as simple as while loop so
just pay attention to the syntax the way
it has been used here so this execute
script is what a simplest statement what
i have used this could be anything it
could be any of your web elements you're
performing certain operations say there
is a calculator which you are using say
a calculator under test so if you want
to key in certain numbers until say the
sum of the numbers is 30 or something an
example like that could be a valid use
case for your while loop so you could
use that so let's execute this and see
how the counter works so if i execute
this command so now take a look at the
log here this is running while test so
first statement where it assigned the
counter value and then it got into the
while loop and it executed the volume
until the counter was assigned the value
5 and once the counter became 5 the
while loop got exited and we are
printing the counter value so this is
how a while loop is used now similarly
the same function of using a counter i
have tried to use a do loop here so
let's look at it now in the do loop what
happens is the first the script is
executed because it's the first command
after the do statement so whatever is
between the do and repeat if is executed
and then the condition is checked here
so here what i'm doing is i'm just first
assigning a counter with value 0 and i'm
incrementing the counter every time by
10 and then i have a condition that once
the counter becomes 50 please exit the
loop that's all i'm doing here and
another statement what i have written
here is every time the counter gets
incremented i am printing the value of
the counter so let's execute this can
you see that the way it is executing it
alright now let's see the lock running
do loop test okay the counter has been
initialized to 0 and then it executes
the script and this script is doing what
it is just incrementing the counter by
10. the counter becomes 10 and then 20
30 40 and 50. so as soon as it becomes
50 it's going to exit the loop and print
the value of the counter so one thing to
notice is there is no web element or
website testing which i am doing from
the script however one thing what the id
needs is it needs a starting point so
whenever you create a new test kit it
asks you to at least give it a url from
where it can start though it is not
going to launch that url it is going to
launch your browser definitely before
even it executes a single line of test
so that is something a mandatory in the
id so we saw do loop we saw the while
loop there is also something called as
time slope so which is what i have said
here times and n so this is something
you can specify a number of iterations
you would like to perform a set of
commands so now in this example what am
i doing i'm simply incrementing a
counter by one right and i'm saying just
increment that is this is the only
command which i want to execute but i
wanted to execute two types that's all
so there is no other conditions here it
is simply saying there is a set of
command or a single command which i want
to execute it twice and the number of
times which i want to execute is what i
mentioned here in the target so first
initially i am assigning a counter with
value 100 and then i am saying increment
this counter by one two times and then
print the value of the counter so let us
execute this and then change the number
of times if i say run test here so can
you see this the number of times it got
titrated and now the value is 102 why
because initial value was 100 in the
loop which is the time slope i am saying
the iterations is 2 2 times execute the
command which increments the counter by
1. so that is why your counter value
becomes 102. now say i increase this to
say 10 so that we get a feel of how the
loop executes here and same thing i will
execute it now see it you can visually
see the number of times the loop is
getting executed all right and in the
log you can see the values also here
okay can you see here so this loop
executed 10 times and hence the counter
value because 110. so these are a simple
ways of using these loops in the id so
you can implement this loops for any
kind of functionality you may want to
perform on your web elements or any
logic which you want to build for your
test cases selenium side runner selenium
side runner is a command line runner
tool which allows the user to run your
selenium id test cases on any browsers
or to run the test cases parallely and
also it gives you a mechanism to use the
grid setup to run your test cases on a
remote machine okay so for us to work
with this selenium side runner there are
certain uh installations which we need
to do and some of the installation
prereqs are one is you need a node.js
server and what is this node.js server
node.js server is a powerful javascript
based platform and this is the platform
which is intensively used by many
developers across the world for
developing their web applications and
it's an open source and it is available
free of cost to everyone to use it so we
will need to go ahead and install a
node.js server for this so now let's
look at all the installation steps which
are involved in installing the side
runner and running it okay so let's go
to my notes so the
seleniumhq.org has a complete
documentation on how to install this
command line runner how to use it and
what are the different ways we can use
this runner i'll just show you where it
is and you can use this as a reference
for any of the tests which you're
creating and using the side runner to
run it
so let me open a new window here let's
go to this website
so if you see here it has a complete
guide on how to use this command line
runner right including the setups what
is the prereqs installing the browser
drivers
and
how do you do the different
configurations which are available with
the side runner so you can configure
various browsers with that you can set
different capabilities for the browser
if you want to use the selenium grid to
run your test cases on remote servers it
also gives you complete details on how
to do that and also using the parameters
changing your base url so this is a
complete guide which you can refer to
when you're working with the site runner
okay so let's go back to our
installation
so coming back to our installation here
so the first prereq what we need for the
selenium side runner to run is your
node.js okay so if you go to this
website nodejs.org
let me open the same
browser okay
all right so here you will see that the
node.js is available as an installable
for all the platforms like do you have a
windows installer you have mac os
installer you have linux installers also
so if you're working with the windows
machine there are two options for you
either you can go ahead and download the
msi installer or you can just download
the zip and unzip it into any folder on
your system okay and since i am using
mac machine what i have done is i have
downloaded this version pkg version and
have installed it on my machine okay so
once you download say if you're working
on the windows machine so say if 64 bit
is what you require and you click here
and download the zip package i'll show
you how the folder structure looks like
so this is where i have downloaded the
node.js installable now if you look at
the windows one so this is what happens
when you download the zip file and unzip
it this is the folder structure it
creates and this is what we would need
right so npm is something which we would
be using to install all the packages
which are required on this node.js
server and i'll explain to you what
those packages are okay so once you do
this installation you need to go and
check if your installation is gone
properly or not so for that what you do
is go to your terminal window or in your
case if you're using a windows machine
just open a command prompt right and
then you have to just give this command
here you say npm minus v which is
basically saying what is the version of
the node.js which we have installed
which is 6.9 okay now what is this npn
npm is nothing but it's a node.js
package manager and it gets installed
with your node and this is used to
install all your other packages or what
it is called as modules on your system
okay so now with this we know that our
npm has been installed properly so let's
move to the next step of installation so
now we have our node.js installed now
next thing is to install the selenium
side runner now the selenium side runner
is a library which is available to us
and we need to install this library
using the npn so let me go back to my
terminal again so i'll just show you the
command what it is what we use for
installing this package or the library
and since i've already installed on my
machine i will not be uh doing the
installation here so what you need to do
so if you are a windows user you can
directly give the command as npn install
minus g selenium site
runner okay so this is the command which
you need to get however if you're a mac
user or a unix user since you need to
use a root user here what you need to do
is just say sudo once you press enter
here it will go ahead and install this
complete library on your system now
since i've already installed i'm not
going to do that okay so i'll just exit
from this now once the installation is
done how do you check whether your
installation has gone correctly or not
you have to just simply give a command
like selenium side runner minus version
okay and now this will give you the
version number if the installation has
been successful so right now the version
installed which is the latest version is
3.11 okay so so far we have done the
installation of the node.js server we
have done the installation of the
selenium now while you also you do this
installation you need to know that where
is the selenium ide side runner has been
installed right as i said it's a library
or what you popularly call as module in
your npm right so for you to check
whether where it has got installed you
simply need to go to the directory i'll
say ls minus user local library so if
you see here you'll see something called
as node modules so whatever packages
you're going to install using npm would
get installed in this directory the node
modules directory so let's go ahead and
see whether i have my selenium side
runner there or not so i'll just use the
same ls slash node modules okay do you
see this selenium side runner is what
has got installed and previously to that
when we installed the node.js server it
also installed this npm right so that is
also available under the same folder so
far so good so we have our selenium ide
installed now what else is required so
we installed the nodejs we installed the
selenium side runner now we need this
browser drivers now what are these
browser drivers now what you did using
your ide was let me
id was we said right in the id itself i
said run the current test and since i'm
using firefox browser here any test case
using the ide plugin on your firefox you
execute is going to execute on the
firefox browser correct same way if you
are using the selenium ide on chrome
which is an extension on chrome and you
run the test cases there it is going to
use the chrome browser to run the test
case however any test cases or any
automation scripts you're going to write
you want your scripts to run on all the
browsers because you want to do a cross
browser testing right so for that
purpose what we do through command line
is we install this browser drivers right
so say if you want to run your test
cases on edge browser so that means you
first need to install your edge browse
driver on your substance before you run
your test case on edge process if you
want to do it for chrome similarly you
need to download the chrome web driver
and install it for firefox the same and
once you install that then you should be
able to run it on any browser now where
are these chrome browsers available so
if you go to the
seleniumhq.org let me show you that
okay in the selenium hq website if you
go to this download tab and if you go
down here you will see something called
as third party drivers bindings and
plugins and here you have a list of all
the browsers and its corresponding
driver files which are available and
this is what which you need to go and
download for example say i want to run
all my tests on chrome browser right so
what i do is i click here okay in the
download session go to the latest chrome
driver available click on that and then
depending on which os you're working on
if you're working on mac just download
this if you're working on uh windows you
download this and once you download the
driver what you need to do is you keep
that drivers like for example uh
can you see this driver file so this is
my driver file this is my executable
driver file so what i did was i just
downloaded this file for mac and i
copied it to the location where my tests
are present okay now so once i have this
available what i need to do is i need to
install this driver using again the npm
command and to install this driver what
you need to do is you need to be in the
same directory where your driver file is
present okay in the same directory you
just issue this command you say npm
install minus g and your chrome driver
this is it so once you install this
driver you should be able to work with
your chrome driver got it very simple so
similarly if you're working with
different browsers say if you also want
to run your test cases with edge or
internet explorer or the firefox browser
same way you need to download all the
drivers from this location
so from here like you have edge browser
here opera browser you have a mozilla
firefox browser so any of the browser
which you want to work with you have to
just download your driver from here
place it in this location and install it
using nbn command okay so since i will
not be executing this command again
because i've already installed it so
once your drivers are installed what's
the next step we are ready to execute
our test cases okay so these are all the
installation steps which are required to
get your command line runner which is
called a selenium side runner ready for
you to execute your test from the
command line all right okay now let's go
ahead and see how do we execute the test
cases so let's go back to our previous
example in this video where we wrote
some of the test cases for testing our
control flows okay so these are all the
test cases now if you observe here i
have not created any test suite here we
just had a default suite which was
created when we created the project and
we just went ahead and created all the
tests here for the side runner to run we
need to have a test suite there so if i
just try to run the test let's try to
run this what is the name of this
project control flows so i'll show you
what happens if there is no test suite
defined for this so let me clear the
screen and ah which is a project here
this one okay so what i will do is let
me simply go ahead and execute this
project so to execute any test this is
the command which you use you simply
call selenium side runner and the
project name okay and also once you have
installed the selenium side runner you
can also check the version of it okay so
let's execute this selenium
side runner and the project name project
name is this
done so now if i press enter now see
what happens okay it's saying running
the default suite carries here
it looks for a test suite to start its
execution okay so it picked up the
default suite which is here
okay since it was created when we
created this new project fine however
it's a test suite failed to run why
because your test suite must contain at
least one test and all our tests are
residing outside the test suite we have
none in the default test way correct so
what we will do let's go ahead and
create this test suite instead of
default what i will do is i'll say first
rename this so let's give it a proper
name so we'll say control flow test test
suite okay done so i have renamed it now
let's go ahead and add all those test
cases which we have created to this so
i'll just simply say add test and select
all these tests so we have around four
tests here so i'll just select all them
done so i'll save this project
i'll go to my folder id tests and the
same file name i'll just say replace now
we have a test suite called control flow
test now let's go ahead and run that
again now let's see what happens
okay so there are multiple test cases
here so let's see all these test cases
will be run one after the other
sequential so we have that calorie
counter test case and then we have the
loop test cases all right so it is done
so now let's understand the flow of this
test case okay so this is where we
started running our test suite so it
finished first test case it finished the
second test case it finished the third
test case and then the fourth test case
so all the four test cases it has
completed and it says all the four
passed total four and it also shows you
the total time taken for the complete
test suite to run and for every test
case what is the amount of time required
to execute that so this is all the
information which is available here if
at all there is a failure in any of the
test case that would get reflected here
it would say four past one phase and
total four executed okay so this is the
kind of report what you will get to see
good so far okay so let's go back to our
notes and see whether we have done
everything so the other way of running
is say you have multiple browser drivers
installed and you want to run this on a
particular browser so during that time
what you can do is you can use this
command you can say selenium side runner
minus c minus c is nothing but setting
the capabilities capabilities for what
for the browser and then you give a
browser name here so you can say chrome
or you can say firefox whatever the
browser of your choice and then give
your project name so with this what
happens is if your browser is installed
now we have to install the browser using
this command correct so if your browser
is installed it will execute this
particular test suite on the browser
which you have mentioned here right and
that is how you use the selenium side
runner to run your test cases on
multiple process now simply what you can
do is you can create a shell script or a
batch script you can add this line into
a bad script for the multiple browsers
and you can execute this so that way all
your test cases would executed on all
the process so that that way you can
achieve your cross browser testing so
other thing if you remember i also said
that command line runner like if you go
back to our presentation it says we can
run it for parallel testing now let's
see how do we achieve this parallel
testing now to achieve this parallel
testing there are certain steps which
you need to do in the id so let's go
back to our test suite so we have this
test suite so if you go here and go to
the settings can you see this run in
parallel so you need to check this check
box to run all these test cases in
parallel so right now what happened when
we executed it all the test cases ran
sequentially one after the other correct
so for every test case there was a
chrome browser launched and the chrome
browser was closed before the next test
was launched now let's try to do this i
am going to check this check box where
it says run in parallel and i will say
submit i'll save this project again now
same thing i'll overwrite this project
save done replace now let's go to our
terminal window and run this test cases
again for that what i will do i'll call
the same command again however now
please observe the number of chrome
browser windows it's going to open okay
i'll show you that so it has started
running the test suite okay can you see
this three chrome browser windows open
at the same time okay and one by one
they're going to get closed out okay so
there was also the fourth one open but
since the test case was so small that it
was too quick for us to see here now
look at the complete execution here so
what it has done is it opened all the
browsers in parallel okay and it ran all
the test cases parallely you will see a
big difference and since these are very
small testers you might not be able to
see a big difference in the execution
time however if you have got a bigger or
bigger test cases which you are running
you will see a remarkable difference in
the time taken by the suite to run the
test cases still here you can see okay
its almost 11 seconds it took whereas in
the previous example it took 13 seconds
as i said the difference is very small
because our test cases are very very
minor test cases right if you have a
bigger test cases where it launches the
browser launches your application under
test then you are doing multiple
operations you will be able to see a
remarkable difference when you run the
test sequentially and when you run it
parallel so this is how you work with
the ide and this is how you achieve the
parallel execution okay so that
completes our selenium side runner now
let's look at some of the limitations of
the selenium id the first limitation is
you cannot export your id scripts to web
driver scripts the support is yet to be
added right so earlier in this video i
showed you there are ways to export the
scripts to junit and python however the
previous ide did have this capability of
exporting your scripts to web driver
scripts and that support is yet to be
added to the new id data driven testing
like using excel files or reading data
from the csv files and passing it to
your scripts so this capability is not
yet available in the id so you cannot do
data driven testing database testing is
also not possible so you cannot actually
connect your database read the test data
from your database or even you cannot
perform any kind of database testing
reporting facility so it does not have a
good reporting we saw when we use the
command line runner or through the id
when we run the test there is a very
minimal reporting capabilities what we
could see so it does not really have ah
capabilities of reporting like your test
ng or the report engine all right so to
sum it up what all we did we learn in
this video we learned how to use the
selenium id to create automation scripts
we also looked at some of the key
features of this new id like the
reusability of the tests using the
control flow statements how do we use
the debugger and most importantly using
the command line runner which is called
a side runner to run your tests on any
browser and also to run test case
parallely so this brings us to the end
of this video so hope you had a good
learning with this video and thank you
very much
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here